WITH. THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
WOMEN RETIREMENT COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON. AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN WRIST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC.
UNITS PROVIDE ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TOLD COVERS
PARTICIPATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE OR RISK THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT SHOULD
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. OF
FOR THOSE OF YOU WITH SCREENS IN
FRONT OF YOU- BUT I WILL
ANNOUNCE THE NUMBERS NOW THAT
THE PARTICIPANT NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO SIX. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE A REPEAT
THAT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO.
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. AGAIN ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR OTHER CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS- IN THIS- STREET
BUILDING AS- EVERYONE HERE KNOWS
BUT FOR THE BENEFIT OF THOSE
ONLINE- I ASK ALL MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AT THIS TIME.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BEGINNER HEARING- I AM
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START THE
HEARING AS A COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE AND THEN WE WILL- COME
BACK IN AND DEAL WITH A QUORUM
AS SOON AS WE CAN WE HAVE EIGHT
BILLS ON TODAY'S. AGENDA. IN FOR
THOSE OF YOU FOLLOWING- AND ALL
THE GENDER- THE FOR S. S. B.
ELEVEN OH TWO. WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY- AT THE CORE AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST. IN THAT WILL
GIVE US THE A BILL SO I JUST
INDICATED- LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR PERVERSE AUTHORS
AVAILABLE HE IS- THAT WOULD BE
CENTER PORTANTINO INDIA'S HERE
TO PRESENT A COUPLE BILLS THE
FIRST ONE IS S. B. ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. CENTER YOU CAN BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- HAPPY
TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN SIXTEEN
WHICH IS ESTABLISHES THE
ACQUITTAL PAYROLL FUN- THE
ACTUAL EQUITABLE PAY ROW FUND IS
A GRANT PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT SMALL NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH IN TURN WILL HELP LOCAL
ECONOMY AND WORKERS DIRECTLY AS
WELL AS THE COMMUNITIES AND-
SMALL THEATERS ARE VIA. TO
ENCOURAGING LOCALS TO BECOME
INVOLVED IN THE ARTS AND ALSO
TO. PRESERVE OUR- OUR STAKE IN
AN ARTISTIC EXPRESSION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT SUPPORTS JOBS FOR
ANYONE HIRED INCLUDING BOTH
PRODUCTION AND NON PRODUCTION
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF. IT IS
FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY AND DIRECTLY
ON SUPPORTING ARCH WORKERS. THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE CALIFORNIAN ARTS
LEADER WORLDWIDE THE BILL COULD
NOT BE MORE TIMELY. AS WORKERS
STILL FACE FAR AND FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES THAN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. ARTS AND CULTURAL
EMPLOYMENT DECLINED TWELVE
PERCENT. IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND TWENTY
ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU BACK.
SYSTEM JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY.
THAT HAS THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE PERCENTAGE OF JOB LOSSES
THAT NONPROFIT ARTS
ORGANIZATION. REMAINS MORE THAN
THREE TIMES WORSE THAN THE
AVERAGE FOR ALL NONPROFITS. SO
THIS IS THIS INDUSTRY THIS.
IMPORTANT VITAL PART OF OUR
CULTURE TOOK A SIGNIFICANT HIT
DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS BILL
WILL HELP THEM. AND WITH ME ON
THE PHONE I HAVE A BRAND
RENDON'S NASH DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS. POLITICS AND
ARIANNA ORTIZ AN ACTRESS AND
FILMMAKER AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE BUT
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WE WILL GO TO. A MISTER LAWRENCE
AT THIS TIME IF YOU THERE YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU- SENATOR
CORTESE THANK YOU WITH YOU TODAY
THANKS VERY PORTANTINO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRANDON AND CAN BE
DIRECT NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR ACT EXACTLY
BOTH THE ASIAN. THE UNION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND ACTUAL AFRICAN EIGHT
MANAGER IN LINE HERE. WE ARE IT
FROM SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN HE'S-
LOOK FOR DETAIL IN OUR RUNNING
FOR WORKERS. CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED NEWARK FAR TOO LONG
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
RIGHT YEAH TWENTY EIGHT OUR
FUNDING ON A PER CAPITA EIGHT.
UNDERINVESTMENT COMBINED WITH
AND THEN MAKE IT THE BEST WAY TO
IT FOR OUR WORKERS- YOU HEARD
EARLIER ARTS AND CULTURAL
DECLINE TWELVE POINT 1% IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY I'M-
THAT DOWN WITH ME ARE ON THAT
UNDER UNEMPLOYMENT. RATE IN THE
RP TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE PRETENSE THAT MAKE
FIVE OR- FIFTY BILL COULD NOT BE
MORE TIME. YOUR EMERGING ARTISTS
VOLUNTEERED THEIR SERVICES OFTEN
FOR YEARS IN ORDER TO BREAK INTO
THE BUSINESS. PREVENTED MANY
FROM ENTERING THE FIELD AND
CREATE A CULTURE OF EXCLUSION.
WE'LL CHANGES THE EQUATION
REIMBURSING OFF ON PROFIT
PERCENT OF PAYROLL. ALSO HAS
IMPORTANT GUARDRAIL ONLY WORKERS
I FIND IT DEPLOYED QUALIFYING
NOT WORKERS MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
EMPLOYERS MUST REPORT
INFORMATION INCLUDING THEIR
DIVERSITY HARASSMENT POLICIES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW BELIEVE
THAT IN JOBS WHERE THE WORKERS
HAVE TO PROTECT AND INCOME WOULD
BE CLASSIFIED AS EMPLOYEES
BEDROCK APART FROM UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS INCLUDING THE AMERICAN
GUILD OF MUSICAL ARTISTS.
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF LABOR
YEAH FOR PRODUCES VEGAS BANK
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS ARE
AMONG THE- WE ARE ARE CONNECTED
BECAUSE THIS. THIS BILL WILL
HELP THE MORE ACTIVE ARE ON THE
OUT. DOING THAT WILL HELP YOU HI
ECONOMY GROWS. STRONGER
ENCOURAGE YOU TO AT THE ELEVEN
SIXTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND- YOU KNOW
BREVITY IS APPRECIATED- WE- LET
ME JUST CHECK AT THE OUTSET OF
THE HEARING IN FAIRNESS TO
EVERYONE- WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TYPICALLY- ALLOWING IN THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CONSULTANT-
HAS A BETTER MEMORY THAN I DO SO
HOPE. WE'RE IN SO MANY
COMMITTEES  THINK WHERE WE HAVE
BEEN ALLOWING- THE MAXIMUM
COMBINATION OF FOUR MINUTES-
WHEN WE HAVE TO LEAD WITNESSES-
IT'S- BEEN IT'S PER WITNESS
OTHERWISE- SO I JUST WANT TO GET
THAT OUT THERE AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE PEOPLE TRYING TO STAY
WITHIN THOSE. BOUNDARIES WE HAVE
MULTIPLE COMMITTEE MEETINGS- A
MEETING ALL DAY TODAY AND SO
FROM TIME TO TIME THE OTHER
POINT OF ORDER I WANTED TO
INDICATE IS THAT- SENATOR OCHO
BOATS ARE VICE CHAIR AND SHE'S
YOUR PRESENT OF COURSE AND I'M
NOT SHE WILL TAKE OVER THE
GAVEL- IN THE EVENT THAT- CENTER
OCHO BOAT. BY SURE IS NOT HERE
SENATOR ALSO. WILL PRESIDE OVER
THE COMMITTEE MEETING OF IN THE
ABSENCE OF THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR AT ANY POINT TIME TODAY SO
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE I APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING THE- MONEY. TO DO A
HOUSEKEEPER. I MEAN OF NOTE- ON
ORTIZ YOU FOR YOUR- IN. IF
YOU'RE ON THE CALL. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU GOODBYE. I
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY
THERE'S A LITTLE FEEDBACK ON THE
LINE WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST GREAT-
OKAY GREAT I AM RE SEE HERE
TODAY AND OF S. ELEVEN ONE AT
SIXTEEN A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY I ARE OUR FUTURE A
PROFESSION ACTOR ALL ALSO
CURRENTLY SIT ON THAT ACCOUNTS
OF THE ACTORS S. B. I
VOLUNTEERED LAST FOUR YEAR IN MY
WITH THE GOAL OF. REPRESENTING
THIS MAFIA KITA AND ARTISTS
COLORS THOUGH STILL AND THE OF
MY UNION SUPPORT IT WITH A GREAT
DEAL TO ME. YOU HEARD ABOUT.
BILL I WOULD. WHICH ARTISTS LIKE
ME. I AM THE DAUGHTER JUST
AMERICAN IN. MARKETERS GIVE ME
MY STARTED MY GRADUATED
COMPUTERS. THE CAL. IS TO THE
ARE. ALREADY I THINK BOTH MY
PARENTS GET A LEADER OF. ALL
THEATER IS WHERE THOUGHT MY- AND
SEX BETWEEN AS THEY VERY UP. IN
THE LARGE WE THEATERS FOR ME. I
PERSONALLY WHEN I GRADUATE WAS
MULTI LOSS IN. MY FIRST ROLE IN
FOR CARE WITHIN A SMALL THEATER
IN IF IT IS TO. DISTRICT HI
COURT. FOR THAT I WAS NOT THE
PATH THANK YOU LOANS FOR
INSTANCE GO TO. WERE IN FILM
TELEVISION. SMALL THEATER
REMAINS RESCUES LARGE AND- ARE
NOT DIG THE CREATIVE RISK NOT
ARE. YOU PROBABLY WON'T SEE BURN
OUT OF WILL BE A THREE PLAY. THE
TWENTY ONE ANYWAY BUT THE ROAD
HERE IN HOLLY. IT'S A SECURE
AGAIN OF REQUIRED OF LET ARTISTS
YOU. WERE TRADE BORDER IN AND
FROM REPEATED IN ORDER TO GET
THE FOR THE LEAD THEATER. THAT
IS REALLY FUNNY VERY I GOT
REVIEWS. AND THE ARTIST COLOR
INVOLVED SENIOR WAYS. THEY NEVER
HAVE THE I'D BECAUSE I FOR THAT
SHOW. AND THE SUPERFUND. SMALL
REPORTING THAT.
SPACES YOU SUPPORT ART BECAUSE
IT IN RICHEST LIVES IN WHICH IS
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THE-
SERVING MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES- AND YEAH. SMALL
THEATERS NEEDED TO SUPPORT
BEFORE CHO SAID NOW WE HAVE A
VERY LONG RECOVERY AHEAD TWELVE
SMALL THEATER TO CLOSE
PERMANENTLY IN THE LAST YEAR'S
NOR CALLING ALONE X. GETS
THIRTEEN. BY PUTTING STILL DO
RIGHT I DO IT IS A THESE ARE
HISTORY. THANK YOU FOR SB. SIXTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE
WILL NOW AND IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN THE ROOM WHO WAS TO.
EXPRESS IS POSITION ON THIS BILL
SIXTY OF SOAP WITH FOR. A SCENE
NONE WAS THE- TO CHECK THE- THE
MODERATORS ALIGNED AND QUEUE UP
IN THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY. IN
FAVOR OF SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE THIRTY
FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD SEARCH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND FOR. THANK
YOU NFL NINE THIRTY NINE IF I
HAD. I AM THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
NINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS
REFLECTED OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARTHA
DENSON I'M THE BOARD PRESIDENT
OF THE THEATER PRODUCERS THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST FONG-
OF XP ALONE HE YEAH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. NEXT HAVE LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN ORDER
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE WITH
HERE'S A LOOK VALLEY INST ITS OF
SB SO. THANKS WE HAVE LINED
EIGHTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JAMES BABIN- PARK WORKER
ACTORS EQUITY AND STAFF MEMBER
ALSO SMALL BUSINESSES REQUIRED
TO GET FIGHT PRODUCTIONS VOICING
MY SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THEN
WE LINE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SCOTT GOLDEN THE
UNION MEMBER OF AFTER ACTOR'S
EQUITY AND ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF
TECHNICAL THEATRE COMPANY LOS
ANGELES MY SUPPORT. ONE ELEVEN
SIXTY. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
LEO MARC ON L. A. AFTER TEN YEAR
MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ELEVEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU. WE
HAVE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU'RE RUNNING ON AN
ADDRESS OF VALLEY OFFERING
BEFORE ME ARE AND I. FOR IF HE
ALLOWED IN. NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING RICH FONG ERMANNO
- LIFETIME- PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND MARK ANGELES
PARTICULAR AND I. SUPPORT AND I
SUPPORT AS. ELEVEN SIXTY. WE
HAVE LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WELCOME TO THE THEATRE
IN SANTA BARBARA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY THANK
YOU. WE HAD LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BENEFITS YOU'RE A MEMBER OF OUR
EQUITY ACTOR WRITER AND LYFT MY
FAMILY STORY OR A ONE MOMENT.
SIX TRYING TO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI FUTURE YEAH RIGHT ON
THE PRODUCE RECKLESS DIRECTOR PRODUCTION AND CLAMOR A
MEMBER ACTORS EQUITY A MEMBER
THE H. IN KOREA SOCIETY AND I
SUPPORT THE LIFELINE BILL. WE
HAVE LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I'M CORY- THAT A
LOT AND THE MEMBER ACTORS BASED
SUPPORTED B. ONE ONE SIX. WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORE MY NAME IS
KELLY BROWN I A MEMBER ACTORS.
FROM NORTH FELLOW- AND MORAN AND
NOT MUCH COUNTY AND I WRONGLY
WRONG SUPPORT AT ONE WAY ONE X.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE IS. THE
HEAD. YES WELL NAME AND A EIGHT
MINUTES LONG THE THIS YEAR AND I
FONG MARK LEVIN AT. ELEVEN
FIFTY. LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY IS SEAN FROM US
ANGELES ANTI BEEN OF THE UNITED
LICCARDO UNION USA TO NINE AM
THE ARK DIRECTOR OF REGARD ON IN
LA AND I AM STRONGLY IN OF THIS
LEGISLATION. WE HAVE LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME THREE HUNDRED
AND I'M CALLING FROM AFROBEAT
YOUNG AND JOSE AND I'M FROM IN
ORDER YOU WANT LOOK THANK YOU
MUCH. NINE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RICK FOR I
AM A OF ACTORS. AND EIGHTY LONG
TIME PART IN SMALL THEATER IN IN
LA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ASKING
YOU TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SIXTEEN THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
AND ALL I AM A FREELANCE
DIRECTOR BASED IN LOS ANGELES
ANY MEMBER AT THE AGE DIRECTORS
AND CHOREOGRAPHERS SOCIETY TRONG
WITH COURT AND YOU ONE ONE SIX
UPDATE OF MY FOR SMALL. SENATE
SUPPORT THAT. MY WE HAVE NUMBER
NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN HER
UNION ACTOR INTENT STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS HERB HALL.
I AM CO PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE BIG THREE
THEATER BURBANK CALIFORNIA I'M
AN ACTOR A MEMBER OF ACTORS
EQUITY ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY FONG- FORTY ONE PLACE.
LINE THIRTY THREE L. S. GOOD
MORNING AND RENEE COOK THE COP
YOU DIRECTOR THREE LA BUT HERE
AT. IT HAPPENED I'M WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY THANK
YOU. THANK LINE NINETEEN FIFTY
GO AHEAD. YES MANY AMEND DELLY
US IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THERE WILL ON THE IN HEIGHTS
ANGELES AND IF SUPPORT IT B.
ELEVEN SIXTEEN THANK. WE HAVE
LINE FORTY FIVE THE GO AHEAD. HI
RICHARD I'M A MEMBER OF THREE
THEATERS AND I ENDORSED ARIANNA
HE- AT OF SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORE MY NAME PAT I'M
A MEMBER OF EQUITY AND THE NEED
THREAT THE SURPLUS YEMENI IN LOS
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY THREE VOTE. BUT LOVE AND
RELISH I'M MEMBER OF GREAT AT.
AT NINE ALL. ONE OF NOT
IMPRACTICAL I WOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT ELEVEN THE BILL. WE HAVE
LINE SEVENTY THEY GO AHEAD.
WEBER MORE ECONOMICALLY WITH THE
STREET IT. AND LYFT PLANS AND I
STRONGLY FEEL THE SLICK. MY
NUMBER OF FOUR THE BILL HAS.
ROCKLIN CA AFTER THE MEMBER
NUMBER OF SMALL THEATRE IN LA
AND I PROBABLY RIGHT AT IT
UNLESS SIXTY THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ARE OKAY. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK THIRTY YEAR LINE UP AND
- GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PARTH
ET I AM A MEMBER OF ACTIVE
ACTIVATE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION. WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BERNARD
OF. AND I'M POLL FOUNDER OF
OPERA AND A MEMBER OF. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO REPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
CHARLES DUNKELMAN SECOND
DIRECTORS TO THE GARAGE IS A
THEATER IN SANTA MONICA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION. WE HAVE LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S SCOTT
FIRESTONE I MEAN DELHI AS THREE
LAMPS HERE MUSICIAN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS LIFELINE BUILT TO
KEEP FEEDER GOING IN CALIFORNIA
SB ONE ONE ONE SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS VIOLET YEAH
AND I'VE DONE USE THE PORT IT'S
BETTER THANK. WE HAVE LINES
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS SYLVIA MARINO AND I MEAN
IF I COULD HAVE DIRECTOR OF
STILL OFFER HEARING CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I AM STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY NINE. THE HEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SHELBY YOU'RE
A BOARD MEMBER OF VALLEY OFF
FROM PERFORMING ARTS AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CEMEX OF SYMPHONY
AND A MUSICIAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT ITSELF. WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YES GO AHEAD. NUMBER
OF THE GOOD MORNING I'M WOULD BE
OKAY THE IT OPENED THOSE WITH
SOMETHING ANGELES IN YOUR LEFT
LEVEL THAT YOU AND I STRONGLY
WHAT IS IT ONE ONE ONE AND
CALIFORNIA COULD BECOME. THANK
YOU. AND I LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES MORNING NAME IS JIM WAS
NOT DAYLON I'M AN ACTOR ACROSS
UNION MAY AND MANAGING OF THE
NEW THEATER IN ANGELES AND I
PROBABLY SUPPORT LEGISLATION.
AND THAT IS ALL THAT I HAVING
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
SO WE'RE GOING TO JUST ASK DOES
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS IN OPPOSITION
POSITION ON SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN. A
SONORA STEP FORWARD MODERATOR A
CAN YOU INQUIRE AS TO WHETHER
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS IN OPPOSITION
POSITION ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO REMIND- THE MODERATORS LINE
IS FOR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY THE LAST. COURT
DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB OVERALL
THERE WAS A LITTLE AD LIBBING OF
THEIR LINES OCCASIONALLY BUT- WE
JUST WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE WHAT
THE RULES ARE FOR THE MODERATORS
LINE THANK YOU MODERATE. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WISH IN
OPPOSITION OF AT. EIGHT ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. ONE THEN ZERO THE TIME. AT EIGHT ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND I HAVE KNOWN IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND- WE CAN'T
ENTERTAIN A MOTION BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY- ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE
COMMENTS AND RUSSELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- I BELIEVE
REALLY STRONGLY IN PERFORMING
ARTS THE CULTURE- THEATERS. IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND I'LL- JUST A
COUPLE OF REASONS FOR THAT- AND
A BIG SHOUT OUT TO ARIANNA ORTIZ
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH. ABOUT
WHAT. ESPECIALLY THE LET THE-
COME. IN THE ARTS- I THIS SOME.
THIS SATURDAY I'M GOING TO A
PERFORMANCE IN BOYLE HEIGHTS AT
GUSTO ONE ONE. AND I HAVE A
GREAT GREAT AFFINITY WITH THE
LATINO THEATER COMPANY THE
SHAKESPEARE THEATRE COMPANY IN
MY DISTRICT AS WELL. OF WHERE
THEY HAVE SPECIAL PROGRAMS FOR
VETERANS AND YOUTH. BUT GROWING
UP AND BEING A PART OF- WHETHER
IT WAS CONNECTED TO THE
FARMWORKER MOVEMENT OR OTHER-
LOOP STUDENT MOVEMENT SMALL
THEATERS WERE OUR WAY OF
EXPRESSING WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT'S HOW A
NUMBER OF THEATER STARTED THE
OTHER COP. STARTED WITH THE WITH
THE- SO IT'S A WAY OF EXPRESSING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OUR COMMUNITY AND I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT MENTAL
HEALTH. OF A OF A DRESS IN ALL
OUR ISSUES. SO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OF ACCESS TO CULTURE AND
ARTS IS THROUGH THESE SMALL
THEATERS- I'VE FOUND THAT THEY
ALSO PROVIDE AN ENTRY LEVEL.
EXPOSURE TO OUR YOUTH SO THEY
COULD SEE THEMSELVES. GOING INTO
THESE FIELDS ALL ON A
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL NOT ONLY ANA
ENTERTAINMENT LEVEL- YOU KNOW SO
THE ARTS THESE SMALL THEATRES
REALLY ARE IMPORTANT TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO DON'T SEE
THEMSELVES GOING TO THOSE BIG.
OF THEATERS- IT CAN BE A COSTLY
OR CAN BE INTIMIDATED WOULD YOU
GO DOWN THE STREET IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS AND WHAT. WHAT IS AN
EXCITING EXPERIENCE THAT IS SO-
AND ALSO MENTION THAT IN MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THAT A DEBBIE
ALLEN DANCE STUDIO WHICH WILL.
BE A GROWING SO I'M- VERY PROUD
TO ALAN I WILL MOVE WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME COMES MOVE THE
BILL- BUT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO OUR COMMUNITY AND- I WILL
PROUDLY REPRESENT THE SENATE AT
UC ALSO ONE ONE IN BOYLE HEIGHTS
THE SATURDAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO- BEFORE WE-
WHEN WE GO AHEAD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND IT'LL MAKE- A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS AND- WE'LL SEE OF
FROM. THE CENTRE WHERE DOES JUST
ARRIVED IN WILL THE SEAPORT WERE
READY TO PROCEED HERE THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTEZ SEE HERE COURTESY
HERE OR TO A BOOK. THE RUSSELL.
THE REST SO HERE LAYERED HERE
LEHRER HERE NEWMAN. WE HAVE A
CORN OKAY THANK YOU CONSUME- LET
ME JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT SEE
OLD CELLS IT ALSO HAS A- A GREAT
SMALL THEATER CULTURE SO THAT
INFLUENCED BY THE FARMWORKERS
MOVEMENT- WE SAW THOSE ANOTHER
SEVEN HAVE BEEN BIG- PROPONENTS
HERE OF COURSE BUT BUT ALSO-
SMALL THEATERS LIKE SALES THE
STAGE COMPANY AND OTHERS WHICH
REALLY PROVIDE. THE THEATER
EXPERIENCE AND IN IN SAN JOSE
SO- I CAN CERTAINLY RELATE TO.
BUY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS-
REGARDING NOTE THAT CULTURE AND
BEING ARTS PATRONS OURSELVES
LOCALLY SO- CENTER WE KNOW- BUT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS AN AUTHOR
FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS-
THERE'S BEEN SOME HARDSHIP AND-
YOU KNOW. THAT'S WHAT LEADERSHIP
BRINGING THIS FORWARD TO TRY TO
MITIGATE THE HARDSHIPS YOU KNOW
ECONOMICALLY THAT'S THAT'S GOING
ON OUT THERE- ANYTHING ELSE-
AGAIN I KNOW. EARLIER JUST CAME
IN FROM ANOTHER COMMITTEE HE'S
NOT. HE'S NOT A LEYCESTER HE'S
JUST. BOUNCING AROUND YOU CAN
SEE A LOT OF THAT TODAY THOSE WE
WERE TRACKING THESE MEETINGS
SENATOR. THERE ARE EIGHT. I HAD
TO PRESENT A LAYERED CORTESE
BUILT IN ELECTIONS. UNAGED WELL
. HI THAT'S WHERE NEW IS AND
THAT'S WHY HE'S NOT HERE. INTO
HAVE STUDIED THIS BILL AND READ
ABOUT IT COULD BE VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR-
BACK TO THE AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE TO ME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND YEAH ARE DISTRICTS ALL HAVE
WONDERFUL SMALL COMMUNITY
THEATERS THAT WE ALL ATTEND. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO SO AND I
THINK- CENTER DRAWS THOSE
CORRECTED MINUTES THE ENTREE
POINT INTO THE ARTS. THE SMALL
COMMUNITY THEATER STELLA STELLA
ADLER ONCE SAID THE THEATER IS A
SPIRITUAL AND SOCIAL X. RAY OF
ITS TIME. AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THESE VENUES- CAPTURE TIME
AND SHARED WITH- YOUNG PEOPLE AS
THEY COME UP AND OBVIOUSLY THE
DIVERSE POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN LASTLY I'LL
QUOTE. SAYS MY WIFE THANK YOU
AND OF ALL I THINK FOR
CONSIDERATION EXCEPT. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. VERY VERY NICE THANK YOU
SENATOR- CENTER GROWS ONE TO
MAKE THE MOTION. WILL COUNT THAT
IS ON THE FLOOR WILL GO TO
CONSOLE FOR THE- ROLL CALL AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS REFERS REFER FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORTES C. HI
COURTESY I OR CHOI BOGUE.
DRESSEL DRESSEL I LAYERED HI
LAYERED AYE NEWMAN. UNCA OKAY SO
THAT HAS- THREE VOTES ENOUGH TO
GET OUT FOR THOSE LISTENING-
THAT'S EXCELLENT- RELIEVED ON
CALLS TO THE ABSENT MEMBERS CAN
VOTE LATER ON- SIR PORTANTINO'S
YOUR NEXT BILL IS S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX ART GET HERE TODAY
AND YOU MAY PROCEED IF READY.
THANK YOU A MESSAGE AND MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY PRESENTING S. B. LEVIN
THIRTY SIX TO CLARIFY AND
STREAMLINE- THE SEQUEL PROCESS
FOR PROJECTS THAT MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE ECESSARY
TO COMPLY WITH OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND WE WANT TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROJECTS WE
DESIGNATE TO GET THERE ACTUALLY
GET BUILT- MEETING THE STATE
AMBITIONS GOALS WILL TAKE A
MASSIVE COORDINATED EFFORT. AS
WELL AS A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN HOWEVER
PROJECTS CAN BE WEIGHTED DOWN BY
INCONSISTENCIES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE CAN MEET ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
TO MINIMIZE UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION OF WORK. AND
EXPENSES SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
WHAT NUMBER ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY LAYERS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR
SPECIFIC PROJECTS WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
WILL EXPAND THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT QUALIFY. STAY
MENTAL IMPACT. AND THEREFORE
ENABLE. IN AND A SKILLED
WORKFORCE. THESE POLICIES WILL
US TO THE BILL OF CLIMB ORIENTED
PROJECTS. BY PROVIDING CERTAINTY
IN DESIGNING FINANCING AND
PERMITTING. TODAY I HAVE CHRIS
HANNON FROM THE LA ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND OBVIOUSLY
IT PROBABLY WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. IF YOU THINK YOU OF
THANK YOU SENATOR- OF
CHRISTIANITY IF YOU'RE- READY
YOU ARE HERE. ACTUALLY OKAY
FORGET THAT I JUST MET YOU FEW
MINUTES AGO- PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY GOOD MORNING HONORABLE-
COMMITTEE CHAIR- HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO AUTHOR MY
NAME IS CHRIS HANNAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE LOS
ANGELES ONE PLEASE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL THIS
MORNING I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THE BEST
TRAINED HARDEST WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY- THE AUTHORS BILL SB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX IS GOING TO
ALLOW FOR. RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES. WE SHOULD CONTROL
THE BASIS NEW. DESIGNED TO MEET
LOWER EMISSIONS. HELP US REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. IT ALLOWS FOR
A FOCUS D. I. R. TO BE COMPLETED
ON THESE PROJECTS NOT SKIRTING
ENVIRONMENTAL REQUIREMENTS BUT
BECAUSE IT WILL REQUIRE
AGENCIES- TO DO OUT FULL ER OF.
CHAVEZ SAYS AND ARE PROJECTS
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR COMPLIANCE
OF THE NEW STANDARDS- THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE USE OF A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE. REQUIRES
THE PAYMENT OF PREVAILING WAGES
WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE BEST
TRAINED WORK FORCE TO WORK ON
THESE PROJECTS TO ENSURE SAFETY
NOT ONLY FOR THEMSELVES. BUT FOR
THE COMMUNITY. THESE WORKERS ARE
HIGHLY TRAINED- THE UTILIZATION
OF THE OF APPRENTICESHIP ALSO
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE HAVE AMBITIOUS AND
JUST. REDUCTION GOALS FOR
GREENHOUSE GASES THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW FOR THE EXPEDITED-
COMPLIANCE WITH NEW REGULATION
AND IT WILL REQUIRE. A SAFE
TRAINED AND PROFESSIONAL WORK
FORCE WHERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THIS MORNING FOR
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WILL
TURN TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS ITS SUPPORT
POSITION ON S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX OF SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
UNSEEN NO ONE- WE WILL S.
MODERATOR TO CHECK. THE PHONE
LINE FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION- IF
ANYONE'S CUED UP. PLEASE LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER OF WITNESSES.
THANK YOU F. YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. SO FAR WE HAVE FOUR LINE FIRST
BILL GO WITH LINE NINETY NINE.
ADDING MORE GEAR. I HAD. MY
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NEXT WHO WILL GO TO NINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
MY NAME'S RICK BUT THERE'S WHICH
REPORTER YOU A LOCAL SEVEN OH
NINE LAFAYETTE. AND WITH THE
BUILDING. ENOUGH SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
NEXT HEADLINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL THE MORE IN TURN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICK SMILED ALMOST BEFORE COLOR
DISTRICT OFFICE OF LABOR AND WE
STAND IN. OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU HAVE LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS READY TO ROLL
BLISS ON WITH THE LABOR DISTRICT
COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANKS VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DANNY BURKE LOCAL THREE
FORTY THREE THE PALMERS DEBATERS
WERE JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE BILL BLACKWELL LOCAL
THIRTY EIGHT SAN FRANCISCO
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX. WE HAVE LINE ONE OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THEY
ARE BISHOP WITH THE- FRANCISCO
BILLION TREES COUNSELING
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWENTY TWO. ONE
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU AND THAT
IS ALL I HAVE THANK YOU RIGHT
NOW. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR WE
DO NOT HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY SIX IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY SIX OF SO.
PLEASE RICE OBSCENE NO ONE A
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE-
ATTEMPT TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON SPLM.
SIX AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BIG ENOUGH OF AT
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
THAT IS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE IN CARE THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE CENTERED ROSA.
THANK YOU LIKE TO- MOVE THE BILL
AND- THANK THE AUTHOR- AND THANK
MR HANFORD FOR COMING AWAY FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO-
EXPRESSED SUPPORT AND FOR ALL
THE GREAT REASONS WERE GRAPPLING
WITH THE ISSUES THAT YOU BALLING
BUT TO GET IN THE IN THE BILL
LIKE THAT GRADING PEOPLE OF HOW.
LABOR STANDARDS AND PUSHING
FORWARD ON- OUR CLIMATE ISSUES
AND CLIMATE CHALLENGES- AND
PUTTING IT ALL TOGETHER IN ONE
IS DOABLE AND SO THOSE WHO SAY
THERE IS THIS CONSTANT THERE HAS
TO BE SOME SORT OF A CONSTANT-
UNTIE. IN BETWEEN LABOR STANDS
BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
BETWEEN. MOVING FORWARD AND- AND
DOING BETTER WITH OUR CLIMATE-
HERE'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE CAN DO AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING SO. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND ALL THE SUPPORT-
THANKS ANDERSON WORTH US SENATOR
ALSO GAVE MY SPEECH AND MADE THE
MOTION I WAS GOING TO MAKE AND
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT. WE SHOULD GET MISSED AND
ISN'T SEAT IN THIS HEARING ROOM
BECAUSE HE HAS BECOME A REGULAR
AND HE SITS ALMOST EXACTLY THERE
EVERY TIME R. HE'S HERE SO
WELCOME BACK ON FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING. OKAY- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO SENATORS AND BACK TO THE
ALTAR IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE NOW
WILL BE A GOOD TIME RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DRAWS SO IN LESS CONSULTANT CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. MOTION IS TO
PASSED. THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY. CURTIS CHAU CHOI BOGUE
WRESTLE. THE REST SO I LAYERED
AYE LAYERED AYE NEWMAN WE HAVE
THREE VOTES OKAY SO- A THREE TWO
ZERO THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET THE
BILL OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU- THE NEXT BILL IN
ORDER SENATOR ALAN IS HE-
PRESENT OR TIED UP. HE WAS. IT
DOESN'T LOOK AT WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR PRESENT AT THE MOMENT.
FROM. OKAY IF WE HAVE WITNESSES
PRESENT WE CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT
NOW- SENATOR ROSALYN INTERNET
CABLE OVER TO YOU SINCE I CAN'T
PRESIDE OVER MY OWN.
PRESENTATION.
ONE OF. ARE YOU TAKEN ABACK.
TAKEN ABACK TAKE IT BACK OKAY.
OKAY. HE HAS BEGUN OPERATION FOR
THE TIME BEING I WILL PUT. FIRST
TRULY BACK TO THE END OF THE
LINE HERE IN- TO SEE SENATOR
JONES IS HERE AS I UNDERSTAND TO
BE SENT- ON CENTER GROVE'S BILL
SB FOURTEEN NINE SURGERIES YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AND- APPRECIATE YOU
MAKING THE COMMENDATION FOR
CENTER GROVE WHO IS OUT THIS
WEEK- AND I HEARING HER BILL AND
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
ASSEMBLE FORTINO NINE WAS
TABLETS A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ABOLISH THE AGRICULTURAL ABLE RE
LABOR RELATIONS ACT ENCOURAGE
AND PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEES AND
APPROPRIATE FUNDS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FARMWORKER
HOUSING. BY JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE L. R. B. TO
SUBMIT TO THE LEGISLATURE REPORT
DETAILING THE PROCESS FOR ITS
ABOLISHMENT. THAT INCLUDES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SUBSEQUENT
LANGUAGE LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE TO
ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
BILL. KERN STATUE PROVIDES THE
ARB WAS SPECIFIC POWERS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH REGARD TO
AGRICULTURAL LABOR DISPUTES AND
REPRESENTATION ELECTIONS.
HOWEVER ACCORDING TO RECENT
CALMATTERS ARTICLE THEY ARE BE
OVERSEAS ANNUALLY JUST ONE OR
TWO UNION ELECTIONS. WHILE OTHER
AGRICULTURAL FACILITIES ARE
DECERTIFYING THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION- INTO A TWENTY
TWENTY NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT
SURVEY FROM UNITED STATES PER OF
LABOR STATISTICS. THE PERCENTAGE
OF CALIFORNIA FARM WORKERS WHO
BELONG TO A UNION IS ASSIST
STATISTICALLY ZERO. WHICH MEANS
THERE ARE SO FEW ACTIVE MEMBERS
THEY FALL WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR. US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
INDICATES THAT THE U. F. W. HAS
ONLY SIXTY SIX HUNDRED ACTIVE
AND RETIRED MEMBERS ACROSS
MULTIPLE STATES. INTERACTIVITY
IN THE AGRICULTURE SECTOR HAS
DECLINED IN PART BECAUSE OF THE
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE DECISION
BY THE US SUPREME COURT CALLED
CEDAR NURSERY VERSES HAS SAID.
THE DECISION OVERTURNED A
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWING UNION
ORGANIZER IS TO MEET WITH
FARMWORKERS AT THEIR PLACE OF
WORK DECLARING THAT IT
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY APPROPRIATES
PRIVATE LAND. SB FOURTEEN OH
NINE WOULD CREATE A PROCESS TO
ABOLISH THE BOARD AND ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT WHAT IS
CURRENTLY SPEND ON THE LRB. ON
ADDITIONAL FARMWORKER HOUSING
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY BENEFIT THE
WORKERS WHO HELP PUT FOOD ON ALL
OF OUR TABLES. SB FOURTEEN OR
NINE WOULD NOT PREVENT UNION
ACTIVITY AT OUR AGRICULTURAL
FACILITIES. IT WOULD SIMPLY
TREAT ACT THE WORKERS LIKE EVERY
OTHER WORKER IN THE STATE AND
ENSURE THEY RECEIVE THE SAME
ORGANIZING PROTECTIONS AS OTHER
INDUSTRIES. TRUE THE LRB IS A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY IN SEARCH OF A
MISSION AND ITS RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE DUPLICATIVE OF OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS MORNING. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IN SUPPORT JEFF
RASMUSSEN WHO IS A FARMER WHO
HAS INTERACTED WITH A R. B. AND
SYLVIA LOPEZ IS A WORK. DAVIS
WHO REPRESENTED THE WORKERS AT
THE GROWING FARMS IN THEIR
EFFORT TO DECERTIFY
REPRESENTATION BY THE U. F. W.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
- THIS RASMUSON YOU ME. IF IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU WONDERFUL
CHAIR IN MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK ON AS THE FOURTEEN OH
NINE. MY NAME IS JEFF RASMUSSEN
I'M NOT HERE TO RIP REPRESENT
ANY SPECIFIC CURRENT COMPANY OR
ORGANIZATION. BE HONEST I WAS A
BIT SHOCKED AND HUMBLED WHEN
CENTER STAFF. INTEGRO STAFF
ASKED ME TO SPEAK AT THIS
HEARING TODAY. MY UNDERSTANDING
SENATOR BOTH COULD NOT BE HERE
BECAUSE OF A FAMILY EMERGENCY
NOPE YOU KEEP HER AND HER FAMILY
MEMBER YOUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
HAVING SAID THAT I'M NOT SURE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE SENATOR. AGAIN
BEING ON THE COMMITTEE. I WAS
SHOCKED LIKE MANY AFTER READING
THIS BILL. I CAN ONLY WONDER
WHAT IS A SENATOR THINKING HERE
TRAINEE. ANY THOUGHTS OF GOOD IN
BOTH GOOD AND BAD AND RUSHED TO
MY HEAD. BEFORE MEETING THE
JUDGES ON THE BILL AND SEND TO
GATHER MORE BASED KNOWLEDGE ON
IT ACCENT THE AGRICULTURE LABOR
RELATIONS ACT AND THE HISTORY.
OF THE LABOR BOARD CREATED SOME
FORTY SEVEN YEARS AGO. I
REFLECTED ON MY LIFE'S JOURNEY
WHEN I FIRST STARTED WORKING
RATE THOSE AT THE AGE OF
FIFTEEN. IN THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. MANY OF MY LIFE
MENTORS ARE OR WERE. A GROUP OF
AGRICULTURE FIELD WORKERS. I
QUIETLY PARTED THE LOW LEVEL
FIVE TO THE YOUNG BOY. THE WORK
HIS FIRST SUMMER JOB. ALVINOLOGY
WHETHER IN ORDER CALIFORNIA. I'M
SURE MANY FARMWORKERS FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING WITH HOUSING THE
LAST TWO YEARS. I'M PUZZLED BY
THE STRUGGLING TO KIND OF BOTH
UNION AND NONUNION AGRICULTURE
WORKERS BUT THE DEMAND YOU CAN
USE TO INCREASE FOR WORKERS. I'M
PERPLEXED THAT WE ALL WANT TO
GET BETTER HOUSING FOR
STRUGGLING FAMILIES YET. IN
GENERAL WE ALL OF THIS WILL
DISMISS SOMEONE SOLUTION. AT
LEAST FOR MY PART I WANT TO ASK
YOU FULLY LISTEN WITHOUT
JUDGMENT THE CENTER GOES DREAM
OF ATTAINING HELD. KATIE
FARMWORKER HOUSING. IT'S A
CLOSED ACCOUNT SICKENING TO BE
HONEST WITH THEMSELVES WITH ONE
THOUGHT. WHAT I OPEN TODAY TO AN
IDEA TO HELP FARMERS FARMWORKERS
FAMILIES TO FILL THEIR DREAMS.
BUT SECURING SAFE HOUSING. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- WILL MOVE ON TO
THE SECOND LEAD SUPPORT WHEN THE
SOVIET LOPEZ IF YOU THERE YOU
MAY PROCEED. SO BILL LOPEZ CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OKAY SO ARE ARE-
OUR STAFF IS TELLING US THAT
SYLVIA LOPEZ IS NOT CURRENTLY IN
THE QUEUE IS BEING COMMITTEE NOT
ON THE COLE I MOMENT CAN I LOOK
AT HER. THANK YOU. ALL OF YOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH- MY NAME
IS ROBIN LOPEZ- I'M FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I'M ONE OF THE
I'M A FARM WORKERS FROM
CALIFORNIA A COUPLE YEARS ABOUT
A YEAR I GOT HERE SINCE I WAS
FOUR YEARS OLD. ALL MY FAMILY
WOULD WORK IN THE FIELD AND I'M
CURRENTLY BAKER. I THINK THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO
SHARE. IT COULD BRING IT UP IN
THE MOMENT. THAT WORKING ABOUT
THE L. A. B. THAT USED TO THE
NIGHTMARE THAT WE HAVE GROWN
FARMING COMPANY- A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- WHEN ELLERBEE A PARTY LINE
VOTE BY LEARN A WORD AWARE OUR
RIGHTS- YEAH. WHEN THEY WERE
WITH A U. S. ASSEMBLY BUT MY I
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT I'M JUST THIS
ONE WERE SHE NOTES UNDER TABLE
THE AYLER B. AND THERE U. S. W.
SEVEN I COULD AND I. DON'T CAN-
DON'T HAVE NO NO WAY TO PROVE
THAT I STARTED MY EYES- BUT THE
L. A. B. IS JUST TO HELP THE U.
S. W. AND NOT THE WORKERS. AND
MY OWN EXPERIENCE AND I WERE
MICHAEL WORKERS ALL THE FROM
WHICH THAT I KNOW MORTGAGE
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS. I BELIEVE
I KNOW MORE FARMWORKERS THEN THE
A LARGE B- AND- A LONG TIME AGO
WE WERE PLANNING AND WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS WITH MY
COWORKERS AND GRANDMA FARMI TO
SHUT DOWN THE L. R. P. I THINK.
I THINK THAT THAT'S OF MY- MAYBE
CAN SO AT MAY. THAT MONEY THEY-
USE IT GOOD HOW US IN THE NEXT
WAY. BUT NOT NOT LEAVING ALL
THAT MY WITH A ALIVE. AND ALSO.
THE U. S. W. AND THE L. R. V.
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH THIS BAD
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM. THEY WERE
ENOUGH TO SEND US BACK TO
MEXICO. SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
THAT MEANS THAT THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE FARMWORKERS. AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WORLD WAR
ONE AND LIKE MANY YEARS AGO TO
SHUT DOWN THE L. A. B. AND
HOPEFULLY- THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S MY EXPERIENCE THAT I
SHARE WITH YOU GUYS- I'M TALKING
THIS I'M SAYING THIS BECAUSE I
LEFT IT WITH WITH WITH MY
COWORKER- THERE MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND WITNESS OF THIS. BETTER
CHOICE AND I'M JUST GOING ON
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK
THIS NEEDS TO STOP. FIFTY TWO
AND- BUT IT'S NOT FAIR FOR THE
WORKERS TO USE OUR NAME SAYING
THAT THERE'S SUPPORT AND TO HELP
US AND THEY'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING FOR A- AND I FEEDBACK
MY- MY POINT RIGHT NOW THAT.
THERE'S NO POINT TO HAVE THE
OFFICE OF THE ELLERBEE WENT
SILENT SHOPPER HE'D TO US. HE HE
CHANGED BUT HE CHANGED
EVERYTHING TO STOP OUR SIGNATURE
THE THIRTY FIVE A UNIT THAT WE
DIDN'T ASK FOR- THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IT MAKES OUR LIFE
VERY DIFFICULT BACK FLYING- WE
WENT TO DEPRESSION WE WENT TO WE
WENT TO A LOT OF WORK FROM
FAMILY THEY SUFFERED TOO MUCH
BECAUSE WE WENT MORE THAN THIRTY
COUNTRIES TO PROTEST. AND COULD
BE HEARD AND THE LRB THEY MAKE
OUR OUR LIFE DIFFICULT. AND I
THINK THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT THE
WAY IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE WHEN IT
COMES- TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
THE FARMWORKERS. MS LOPEZ I'M
GONNA HAVE TO ASK YOU TO WRAP UP
WE ACTUALLY ONLY ALLOW TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS SO THAT YOU
GO OVER A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OF
YOUR- LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
STORY- IN THE FIRST WITNESS WAS
VERY BRIEF BUT YOU HAVE TO. WRAP
UP NOW IF YOU WANT TO CLOSE WITH
ONE SENTENCE THAT WOULD BE FINE
. YES I THINK THIS IS THE MOMENT
TO END WITH THE LRB. SHUT IT
DOWN OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY PRETTY CLEAR. THANK
YOU FOR. OKAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEADERSHIP POSITION LISTED ON
THIS. THE BILL I'M SORRY LET ME
COME BACK TO THE ROOM- I SKIPPED
TWO IMPORTANT STEPS HERE ONE OF
THEM IS- WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THEY'LL BE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION OBSCENE NINE MODERATOR
WHICH PLEASE A CHECK OF THE
PHONE LINE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION
ON SB FORTINO NINE. YOU CAN
SUPPORTIVE SB FORTINO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST WE'LL GO WITH LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE WONDER VIA NUMBER I WILL
LOOK BACK. FOR YOUR IT'S NOT THE
SETTLEMENT WELCOME ANALYST
INPUTS OKAY GOT BEEN FIVE YOUNG
MAN THANK YOU FELT PHENOMENA
YEAH THANK THEM AND FELLOW THERE
ONLY KNOW WHAT I'M IT'S- THAT
GOD. THAT ARE. MODERATOR- IT'S
BEEN A WHILE WE SO MUCH BECAUSE
- IN THIS CAN ON THE ON THE
PHONE LINE IS- TRANS- TRANS
INTER BUILD- FOR PHONE WITNESSES
. IF NOT. I A NOTE WE HAVE. FOLK
HERE WHO UNDERSTAND ALL OF WHAT
WE JUST SAID IN AN A COUPLE
HUNDRED SOME WHAT WAS JUST SAID
I LISTENING I WAS LISTENING
EVERY DETAIL TO TRANSLATE BUT G.
R. SUPPORTED THE BILL AND GAVE A
REASON OR TWO WHY RIGHT. WITH
DOLLARS. WE SHOULD BE HEARING
NAME OF AND POSITION BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
WAS JUST PUT ON THE RECORD IS
CLEAR SO YOU. YOU AGREE WITH
THAT WE HAVE. I THINK WE HAVE A
TWO. OF OUR MEMBERS. VALIDATING
THAT THAT WAS JUST A SUPPORT
POSITION THAT WE WAS REPORT YES
THANK YOU STATED THAT SHE LIKES
TO SEE. OUR TAX DOLLARS BEING
WELL SPENT OKAY SO SHE ACTUALLY
SET A LITTLE MORE THAN. RIGHT
ALLOWED. THANK YOU. HER NAME-
WHEN SHE DID IF YOU DID YOU CAN
RESTATE IT FORCED WATER. I DID
NOT BUT I'M A MOMENT IN YOUR IN
THE NUMBER. YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF FUN. OKAY THANK YOU
THAT'S ON THE RECORD NOW WE ARE
THAT THE MODERATOR PLEASE
PROCEED WITH SUPPORT WHEN THIS
IS. WE HAVE LINED ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANNA FIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT ONE OF THE
HEAD. WE'LL GO WITH LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MARK
SHOCKED THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE- STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
AGAIN THIS IS A SUPPORT LINE A
MODERATOR NO YOU MADE THAT CLEAR
ONCE BEFORE BUT WE WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR. AGAIN YES. THERE IS FEAR
IN SPEAKING OUT IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN OH NINE. IF NOT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOOK HELLO. PLEASE CONSIDER ME
YES PLEASE PROCEED YES. WELL
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S CARLOS
LOPEZ- JUST LIKE THAT. YES BOB
SPEAKER UP I BELIEVE ARE LETTER
TO BE THAT RIGHTLY SORRY ONLY A
THE STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
ISIS THAT. OR AT THE ON A THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR UP. WE HAVE A WENT
AWAY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY
NAME IS ZERO ON BEHALF OF PICKED
UP AND TELL FORMER AND FOUND AND
THEN I 9% FORMER USE THAT UP.
BETTER NOW REPRESENT BY THE W.
I. STRIKES AND FORTY ON I THINK. THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE
NO THINK RIGHT NOW. OKAY THANK
YOU- NO AS I STARTED TO SAY WE
DO NOT HAVE A LEAD- LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS BILL
SB FORTINO NINE IS OR ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION. OBSCENE NO ONE
COME FORWARD MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON- THERE IS THANK YOU
POLICE A STEP FORWARD YOU'RE
ENTITLED VERY WELL WITH UFCW
WESTERN STATES COUNSEL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM I DIDN'T MEAN
TO- RUSH THAT. OKAY THANK YOU
AND BACK TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN QUEUE UP ANY. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. THE
FOURTEENTH ZERO NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND FOR IT
TO GO TO LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MUCH CIDER WITH-
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR GOOD JOB
WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. DOES SENATOR ALSO
YES- I MEAN I'M- FOR ME HAVING
SPENT SO MUCH TIME BOTH WORKING
IN THE FIELDS AND- WITH WORKERS
WHO- FIGHT EVERY DAY TO GET THE
KINDS OF WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT THEY DESERVE
SOMETHING THAT'S FAIR ON THE
JOB- IT'S QUITE SURPRISING THAT
ANYBODY WOULD OPPOSE ABOLISHING
AN AGENCY WHOSE ONLY JOB IS TO
TRY AND GIVE WORKERS THAT VOICE
THAT THAT THEY NEED AN AGENCY
WITH A VOICE THAT THEY THEY NEED
SO. I AM VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS- AND I HOPE IT INSTEAD
WE SHOULD FOCUS ON WHAT THE
WORKING CONDITIONS ARE OF THOSE
ON MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO SO MUCH
FOR THIS NATION- IT'S SHAMEFUL
THAT. WE WOULD TRADE THEIR
DEMOCRATIC RIGHTS ON THE JOB
FOR- HOUSING MEANS THAT SHOULD
NOT P. EVEN ON THE TABLE WHY
CAN'T THEY HAVE HOUSING AND-
DEMOCRATIC RIGHTS ON THE JOB SO
. I COULD GO ON AND ON I'VE MADE
MY POINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
WITH WE ARE IN TOTAL RESPECT FOR
THE TESTIMONY OF. OF THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- MY
EXPERIENCE BOTH AS OF THE PRO
BONO ATTORNEY OVER THE YEARS- IN
IT ALSO HAS- A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL- IS ALMOST ENTIRELY
OPPOSITE OF WHAT I HEARD THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT ISN'T HER
EXPERIENCE BUT- I WANT TO
EXPLAIN. WHY I'M- VOTING THE WAY
I WILL BE VOTING ON THIS BILL
WHICH IS NO- WITHOUT- BENE-
CHARACTERIZEARE UNDERSTOOD AS
BEING DISMISSIVE OF THE
WITNESSES COMMENTS I JUST WANT
TO WITNESS UNDERSTAND. THAT MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DEGREES DIFFERENT OVER
ALMOST THREE DECADES SO OF A
PERHAPS LONGER WHAT THE MYSELF
ANY FURTHER- ANYONE ELSE-
SENATOR OF A PLEASURE WHICH-
BOTH DID YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED I KNOW I KNOW NO
COMMENTS I'LL JUST MOVE THE- THE
BILL WENT. FROM THE COMMISSION
TO THE BILL- AT THE PROPER TIME
OKAY THANK YOU SO WE HAVE THE
OFFER OF A MOTION THE BY- BYE
BYE CHAU CHOI BOGUE INCOME BACK
TO SENATOR JONES- PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF CENTER GROVE YOU MAY
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AND IT'S AND
CERTAINLY THE TESTIMONY IS
COMPELLING IN AND- YOUR COMMENTS
ARE AS WELL. MISTER CHAIR AT YOU
KNOW ONE THING WE CAN'T DISMISS
TODAY IS OUR COLLEAGUES PASSION
FOR REPRESENTING HER DISTRICT
AND THE- THE WORKERS IN THE AND
THE FARMS IN HER AREA AND OF
COURSE STATEWIDE. AS SHE HAS
SPENT- A RESPECTABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME ON THESE ISSUES. MEETING
DIRECTLY WITH HER CONSTITUENTS
THAT WORK IN THE FIELDS TO PUT
FOOD ON ALL OF OUR TABLES I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR-
SOME OF THESE- FARMS AND.
AGRICULTURAL AREAS AND I'M- ALL
A MAIN AT THE TO. OF THE CREW
THAT WORK- IN THESE FIELDS TO-
GET THE FOOD OFF THE GROUND OUT
OF THE GROUND OFF THE TREES AND
IN THE TRUCKS AND PACKAGES- TO
OUR LOCAL STORES. I THINK THAT-
GIVEN THE TIME THAT SHE HAS
SPENT ON THIS ISSUE SHE HAS A-
DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF THE L. R.
B. AND- EFFECTIVENESS OF IT.
THERE'S SOME SEVERAL STATISTICS
THAT I WANT THAT SHIRT IN THE
OPENING BIT JUST SHOWS THAT YOU
KNOW AS- AS GOVERNMENT MOVES ON
SOMETIMES- PROGRAMS ARE PUT IN
PLACE THAT SEVERAL DECADES LATER
THEY'VE- ACCOMPLISHED. WHAT THE
ORIGINAL CHARTER WAS THEY'VE
MADE THE POSITIVE CHANGES THAT
THEY NEED TO MAKE AND NOW THAT
THAT CONCEPT HAS MOVED ON AND
MAYBE THAT'S THE CASE WITH A R.
B. AND IT IS TIME TO. DISBAND
IT- CLOSE IT AND MOVE THOSE
RESOURCES TO OTHER. POSITIVE
ASPECTS THAT WE CAN MAKE FOR
FARMWORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND AS HAS BEEN
SAID THAT IS HOUSING I ASKED HER
AYE VOTE TODAY. WE'RE DOING
THANK YOU SENATOR- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY BY ZERO TWO OH BOGUE-
IN WILL GO TO THE CONSOLE NOW
FOR THE ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CORTES C. NO COURTESY NO OR
TROUBLE HI A TROUBLED BY THE
RUSSELL. RUSSELL NO LAYERED.
LAYERED NO NEWMAN. WE HAVE SO
THE VOTERS- ONE I. RENO'S ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS SO WE WILL LEAVE-
WE WILL LEAVE THE ITEM ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
AGAIN CENTER THANK YOU RICHARD
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR PETITIONS
RAMPS. RATE THE ORDINARILY WE
WOULD GO GOING TO SENATOR ALLEN
NEXT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU LEFT THE
ROOM AND SO CENTER DOLLY IS HERE
ON- SURROUNDED UGLY. THEY'RE
ALMOST ALMOST. ALL WE WERE A HAS
TEN WITH WITH ABOUT THE
POLITICAL OUTSIDE JUST WAITING
WAITING FOR THIS BILL TO FINISH
THEM THANK YOU. THIS IS YOUR-
HOPEFULLY THIS WEEK. IS
ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS I
DO APPRECIATE THAT THAT YEAR AND
THE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS- YOU KNOW FOLKS YOU YOU ALL
KNOW COURSE HOW MUCH THE COVER
NINETEEN- PANDEMIC CREATED- SO
MUCH UPHEAVAL AND PROBLEMS FOR
OUR- FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR FOLKS
ALL OVER THE WORLD. UNEMPLOYMENT
COURSE TYPICALLY RISES STEADILY
OVER THE COURSE OF RECESSION.
BUT THE PANDEMIC IMMEDIATELY
SHOCKED ECONOMY WITH THIS.
MASSIVE SPIKE IN UNEMPLOYMENT
THAT SKYROCKET TO A RECORD
BREAKING 16% OVER THE COURSE OF
ONE MONTH. EVERYONE REMEMBERS
THAT SO MANY WHO STRUGGLE TO
AFFORD NECESSITIES TURN TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT DISABILITY
INSURANCE SYSTEMS FOR CRITICAL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. BUT THIS-
THIS WHOLE APPROACH HIGHLIGHTED
A LOT OF THE INEQUITIES IN THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. FOR A SELF
EMPLOYED WORKERS. WHO ORDINARILY
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO COLLECT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
. SO WE HAVE THE FEDERAL CARES
ACT A COURSE WHICH CREATED THE
PANDEMIC ON EMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- THAT A LOT
OF OUR STOPS WERE HELPING
PEOPLE. NAVIGATE DURING THE
PANDEMIC GOT OF COURSE PROVIDED
SELF EMPLOYED WORKERS WITH
ACCESS TO UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
FOR THE FIRST TIME. AND IN THE
FIRST JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF THE SCALE OF THE USE OF THIS
IN THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS THE
PANDEMIC FROM MARCH TO JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY- SOMETHING LIKE
FOUR MILLION. CALIFORNIANS
THAT'S 10% OF OUR TOTAL
POPULATION. HI THE FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS VALUE I CLAIMS WITH
THE STATE'S UNEMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT EDT
ANOTHER SWAN MILLION SELF
EMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS. ARE FILED
P. U. A. CLAIMS. SO EDT ISSUED
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN BENEFITS IN THE SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN. SO NOW THESE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN PANDEMIC
YOU'RE A PROGRAMS HAS ENDED. HI
WE NOW HAVE SELF EMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS WHO NO LONGER HAVE
ACCESS TO BENEFITS WHERE THEY
CAN'T FIND WORK. SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE THE CANDY FOR MY STAFF OUR
STAFFS ALL OF OUR STUFF WERE
JUST. WENT THROUGH A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME AS WE KNOW TAKING
ALL THESE CALLS FROM PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT THEIR LAST LEGS. I AND
THE THROUGH HROUGH THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION WE GOT TO A PLACE
WHERE WE CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
TO TRY TO SEEK A PERMANENT
SOLUTION. TO ALLOW INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT BENEFITS ONCE IT WHEN
FACING WORK SCARCITY. AS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS THERE ARE SO
MANY VITAL QUESTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ANSWERED FOR A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS TO BE EFFECTIVE- THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WILL
RESHAPE THE BILL. TO OPTIONS FOR
AN ELECTIVE COVERAGE PROGRAM.
ULTIMATELY WHAT OUR GOAL HERE IS
TO FIND HOW BEST TO EXTEND
PROTECTIONS FOR THE SELF
EMPLOYED. EITHER ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED TO EDIT THE TRADITIONAL
EMPLOYEES- IN THE WORK FORCE
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT- I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU KNOW
GARRETT AND MY TEAM LOS ANGELES
LILLIAN JAMIE AND- I CAN ONLY
NINE AND- ALL THE ALL THE ALL
THE FOLKS IN MY- MY TEETH WERE
TAKING THESE CALLS DAVIS IS RAD-
THE- THEY CAME TOGETHER TO.
ADDICTED TO GO THINK THROUGH
THESE IDEAS TALK TO MANAGER
STAFF. AND- I'M AND THIS IS VERY
MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS WE'RE
NOW. AND IF ASK. TO LOOK INTO
THIS ISSUE. BUT IT'S A VERY REAL
ISSUE IT'S ONE THAT WE'RE AWARE
OF GIVEN. EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED AND I WOULD CERTAINLY.
ASK YOUR EITHER. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO OF. THERE'S NO- LEADS.
WITH ON- ON THE BILL I NOTICED
YOU DIDN'T MENTION ONE SO I'M
GOING TO I'M JUST A FIRM IN THE
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
ALL RIGHT YEAH THIS IS VERY MUCH
FROM US. RIGHT I'M JUST GONNA
ASK YOU IF- THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SPLM THIRTY EIGHT IF
SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD- SEEN.
NONE WAS MODERATOR OF THE ANY.
ON THE PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT. PART OF IT YOUR AT
ELEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO YOUR PHONE. ONE AND
NOW. I HAVE ONE IN OVER A- THING
YOU FOR CHECKING- THERE'S NO
BLEED OPPOSITION WELL THERE IS
LISTED IS ROBERT MOTOR HERE YES
PLEASE COME FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIR OF MORNING
SANTA ROSA CENTER LAYERED
THROUGH ALLEN A RUBBER MACHINE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE OPPOSITION ALONG
WITH THE COALITION APPRECIATE
DISCUSSIONS THE AUTHOR STAFF ON
THIS END OF THE COMMITTEE
CONCERNS OUTLINED- WE EXPECT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WHEN THEY'RE
PRINT TO TAKE US OFF OPPOSITION
THE BILL AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
IS HERE TO SHARE THE- THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU- ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE COME
FORWARD MODERATOR- LIST GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. WE
CANNOT POSITION AT THE F. EIGHT
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO AT EIGHT THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE
NO ANY CARE. OR IT WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AT THAT
THIS TIME CENTER YES SIDE A
QUESTION AND IT'S- IT AB THE
AUTHOR SAID IN HIS OPENING
STATEMENTS THE AMENDMENT TO
HELP. AND THEN THE TESTIMONY
SAID WHEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE IN
PRINT AND WE HAVE THE AMENDMENTS
IN FRONT OF US SO I WAS GONNA
ASK WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE THEY IN PRINTER
YOU TAKING ON TODAY. A. N. D. IS
IT CAN SOMEBODY JUST GIVE A VERY
VERY BRIEF SUMMARY OF WHAT THEY
DO. THE AUTHOR SAID HE WAS
ACCEPTING THE OF MSE THEY WERE
PRETTY WELL I JUST DIDN'T HEAR
IT THAT QUICKLY SO I DEFINITELY
I'VE GOT- I'VE DEFINITELY SENT
TO THE MEMBERS. OKAY ARE THEY IN
PRINT IT- NO I DON'T BELIEVE SO
OKAY. SO I'LL GIVE IT WOULD HAVE
TO DOUBLE. OKAY COME IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY AND
CAN SOMEBODY TELL ME AND A
SICKLY. SOMEBODY'S POINTING WHAT
THEY'RE BEING TAKEN HERE. OKAY
SO CAN SOMEBODY TELL ME BRIEFLY
WHAT THEY DID THREE BASICALLY
RESHAPES THE BILL TO- INSTEAD
REQUIRE THAT YOU DID YOU EXAMINE
THESE QUESTIONS. AND THEN REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON A
POTENTIAL STRUCTURE. IN OPTIONS
FOR AN ELECTIVE COVERAGE PROGRAM
SO DOES IT DO THE PROGRAM
DOESN'T PROVIDE TO PROCESS TO
CONSIDER IT AND THEN THAT'S
RIGHT FOR THE DECIDE IT TURNS
OUT I MEAN. AS YOU MAY EXPECT
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLICATIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO SELF EMPLOYED
RIGHT HOW DO YOU. WE HAVE
EMPLOYED PERSON YOU HAVE A VERY
CLEAR NOW I SEE A- SELF EMPLOYED
LEGISLATURE. CAN FACES BEHIND.
YES THE RECORD YEAH YEAH RIGHT
THOSE OF YOU AT HOME OR BECAUSE
OF YOU AT HOME COULDN'T SEE IF
YOU KNOW AND OUT AND THEY KNOW
IT IS IN YOUR NOW SOMETHING
SEVEN LIKE THAT THE FOLKS FROM
THE CHAMBER AND OTHERS. RAISED
YOU KNOW A LOT OF. LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WHICH HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH AND FIGURE OUT THIS IS A
REAL PHENOMENON. OUR SYSTEM
DOESN'T. PROVIDE FOR THESE FOLKS
AND THEIR REAL PART OF OUR
ECONOMY. AND THIS CRISIS SHOWED
UP OF A GAP IN OUR SYSTEM. WOULD
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A GOOD WAY
TO. ADDRESS IN. THE FUTURE THEN-
MISTER CHART WITH THE AMENDMENTS
I WOULD MOVE TO DO. THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME JUST SOME. LET ME
JUST READ. ESSENTIALLY THE LAST
PARAGRAPH OF. THE BILL IT THIS
IS STANDS NOW WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY THE- I THINK THE
CRUX OF THE AMENDMENT. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE EDTA TO
CONDUCT A FEASIBILITY STUDY S.
SPECIFIED. THAT EXAMINES THE
IDEA BECAUSE THEN IN
TO SELF EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS.
AND REPORTS ON WHAT ACTIONS ARE
NECESSARY. TO IMPLEMENT THE
EXPANSION. BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE EDT TO COMPLETE. AND SUBMIT
THE FEASIBILITY STUDY TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT. BUT
DECEMBER ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
SO THERE'S A- FINITE TIME PERIOD
AND- I JUST WANTED. TO GET THAT
ON THE RECORD AND- IT ALSO THANK
THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR. WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE STAFF- YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES- SPEAKING LIKE I JUST
READ MIGHT SOUND LIKE KICKING
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD I DON'T
THINK SO- I THINK THIS IS A HUGE
ISSUE. I THINK IT'S AHUGE
STRUCTURAL ISSUE. IN I THINK
WE'VE ASKED FOR THE MOST RAPID
TURNAROUND. WE COULD REALLY TO
GET A NEW STRUCTURE BEFORE US
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE. SO WE
KEEP MOVING FORWARD WITH THEM
WITH YOUR INTENSE I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT. AND- YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE. FOLKS KNOW THAT
THIS IS VERY REAL. AND- IN WE
TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY THANK YOU
CENTER DROSE OKAY. YEAH I'M GLAD
YOU ENDED UP A WE DID- SYNDROME
BECAUSE THIS. THE IS THE
BIGGEST. AND THEY A LOT OF
REASONS. IT JUST. SIXTEEN SORT
OF EXPLODED THE WAY THAT IT DID
DURING PANDEMIC OR HEART OF
THIS WAS THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
MASSIVE. OF ABUSE OF THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR STATUS.
AND SO. MANY I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER BUT- MANY. OF WHO
SHOULD BE EMPLOYEES IT WOULD BE
COVERED WITHOUT ANY PROBLEM-
WERE EITHER REQUIRED TO TAKE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR STATUS OR
THEY WANTED TO TAKE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR STATUS AND THAT OF
COURSE. LEFT THEM OUT OF THE
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE NOBODY WAS
PUTTING IN THERE I CAN YOU PICK
OUT. EVEN NOT PUTTING IN AND IF
YOU FOLLOW THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR STATUS THERE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN AS MANY PEOPLE
IMPACTED OVER UP BY THAT SO I
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
CONNECTED ISSUES. OF THAT I HOPE
ARE INCLUDED IN THE STUDY- WOULD
BE NICE TO SORT OF GET DIFFERENT
PEOPLE'S UP BEFORE YOU DO THAT
BEFORE THEY DO THE STUDY IS WHAT
THEY THINK SHOULD BE INCLUDED.
YOU KNOW IN THAT. OF BUT I KNOW
BEING SELF EMPLOYED IS REALLY
DIFFERENT FROM BEING AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR WHERE IS
THE MONEY GOING TO COME FROM WE
JUST HAD- THE NUMBER PROPOSALS
ON HOW WE HELP BUSINESSES. ON
THE COST OF EDT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND SO THAT'S A LOT
THAT'S A LOT TO. PUT INTO IT MHM
THE BOTTOM LINE IS I'M
SUPPORTING BECAUSE I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU PUT IT INTO THIRTY FOUR
BEFORE. US TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER TO SUPPORT OR
NOT SUPPORT OF AN ACTUAL PROGRAM
YEAH THANK AND THE IDEA IS THAT
IT WOULD BE AN ELECTIVE COVERAGE
FOR. SO THAT'S AT LEAST A
CONCERT. WITH DRESSIER I MEAN
WAS REFRESHING TO HAVE. SOME
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE. NOT PAID
INTO THE SYSTEM THEN SOMEHOW
TURN AROUND TRY TO GET. FAST FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES TO BE COVERED
YOU KNOW- OF THE WAY I WAS WHAT
. THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN
CENTER IN ITALY JUST CLARIFY FOR
THE RECORD SO I DON'T MONEY IT
UP THAT THE PORTION OF THE MEN'S
AT THE MOMENTS THAT I READ WERE.
WERE A PORTION- I JUST THE CRUX
OF THE AMENDMENTS- BUT THAT
WASN'T I DO WANT TO READ THEM IN
ENTIRETY CENTER OUTLINED ON PAGE
SIX IF YOU KNOW SOMETHING THEY
ARE IN- IN THERE THEY'RE A
LITTLE MORE DETAILED- QUITE A
BIT MORE DETAIL IN TERMS OF
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WOULD COME
BACK. MITTY BY DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED. AND
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS JUST ARRIVED
ON A GIVEN OPPORTUNITY TO. GET
SITUATED SENATOR NEWMAN- WE ARE
- ON. ALLEN'S BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. AND HE HAS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS- THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I JUST WENT OVER THOSE
AGAIN HE'S CONCLUDED HIS
PRESENTATION AND DID YOU WANT A
FURTHER OPPORTUNITY CLOSE I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR-
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET OUT HERE AND- REALLY HOPE
THIS WILL HELP TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN
THAT THEY COULD REALLY. HELP A
LOT OF PEOPLE ALL RIGHT BUT WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD IN- S.
CONSOLE MICHAEL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST AMEND AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. COURTESY HI
COURTESY HI A CHOI BOGUE. TO
WRESTLE. THE REST SO I LAYERED.
LAYARD I NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL VOTE FOR VOTES-
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WILL KEEP IT OPEN- FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. IN
THE NO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY CENTER
GOALIE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE RESHOOT YOU BEING HERE
AND WALKING A PERCENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I. WILL COME LOOK
TO THIS COMMITTEE OFTEN BUT I'VE
HAD SOME LUCK HERE. AND I HAVE A
THE BILL APPEARED SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY. IT'S COMPLICATED BUT I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE TALK
ABOUT UNDER CALPERS CURRENT
REGULATION. REGULATIONS MEMBERS
ARE ALLOWED TO TRANSFER BETWEEN
CONTRACTING AGENCIES AND RETAIN
THEIR PENSIONS UNDER PUBLIC.
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT FUND. WHEN
AN EMPLOYEE'S COMPENSATION IS
INCREASED ACTUAL LIVE BILITY
RELATED TO THEIR PENSION IS
INCREASED AS WELL CURRENTLY ALL
PROVISIONS. ALL PREVIOUS
EMPLOYERS SHARE THE INCREASEIN
ACTUALLY LIABILITY WITH THE
CURRENT EMPLOYER IF AN
EMPLOYEE'S COMPENSATION IS
INCREASED. PREVIOUS EMPLOYERS
AGENCIES MAY HAVE TO INCREASE
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO FORMER
EMPLOYEES BEYOND THEIR ACTUALLY
PROJECTIONS THEY MADE WHEN THEY
WERE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE EMPLOYEE. FURTHER WHEN
ORIGINAL EMPLOYEES LEAVE FOR THE
OTHER AGENCIES AGENCIES SPEND
ADDITIONAL TIME AND FUNDS HIRING
AND TRAINING NEW EMPLOYEES. THEN
THEY MUST INCREASE CONTRIBUTIONS
WHEN EMPLOYEES A TRAINED RECEIVE
RAISES AT LATER AGENCIES. OUR
BILL REQUIRES ENTITIES
CONTRACTED WITH CALPERS TO BARE
FULL FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ANY ACTIONS THAT WOULD
INCREASE ACTUARIES. LIABILITY
FOR A MEMBER'S PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
FROM ELDORADO COUNTY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT CHIEF PAUL
DUIT WHO IS THE FINANCIAL AND
RISK OFFICER ALONG WITH DIRECTOR
PAUL GILCHRIST. WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION FIVE SO
I HAVE MY WITNESSES UP. NOTHING
THANK YOU SENATOR- CHIEF PAUL
DUTCH IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE YOU
MAY PROCEED AT THIS TIME.
MORNING MY NAME IS PAUL DUTCH
AMONG DIVISION CHIEF WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY.
ONE TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE HAPPENING WITH
INDEPENDENTS ABOUT SPECIAL FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION OF GASPING NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT THE FIX
SUMMARIZATION UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES. INDEPENDENT
DISTRICTS RECEIVE ROUGHLY 80% OF
THE REVENUES FROM AD VALOREM
TAXES. THIS LIMITED REVENUE
BASIS SIMPLY NOT DESIGNED TO
ABSORB INCREASING PENSION
LIABILITY COSTS FOR SOME OF HIS
LIFE. THE EXPECTED TO MAINTAIN
COMPETITIVE SALARY SCHEDULES
WITH COMPARABLE AGENCIES. AN
ILLUSTRATION HIS PHYSICAL
LIMITATIONS CAN BE OBSERVERS
WITH THE POPULARITY AN
INCLINATION FOR PUBLICATIONS IS
TO LEVERAGE PENSION OBLIGATION
BONDS SO THEY CAN FREE UP NEAR
REVENUES FOR OPERATIONAL COSTS.
THE ARGUMENT FOR MAKING CHANGES
TO RECIPROCITY FILLED WITH
KNOWLEDGE THROUGH FISCAL
REALITIES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN OPPOSE PROP THIRTEEN POSTS
YOU ROUGH WORLD. WITH THE
SMALLER FORMS OF GOVERNMENT ARE
BOUND BY THE FINANCIAL AXIOMS
BUT NO AVAILABLE MEANS OF
REVENUE RELIEF OTHER THAN
ATTEMPTING TO GET A TAX MEASURE
PASSED. REQUIRING TWO THIRDS OF
VOTER APPROVAL NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
FEAT IN TODAY'S INFLATIONARY
WORLD. FOR SYSTEM TRULY THE
RECIPROCAL MUST BE RECIPROCALLY
FARE AND PREDECESSOR AGENCIES
HAVE THE PENSION COSTS INCREASED
BY ROUGHLY FORTY PERCENT. FOR
RESPECTIVE EMPLOYEE FROM
SUCCESSOR AGENCY PENSION
INDEXING THIS HARDLY SEEMS
RECEPTACLE NOTED THAT SEEM OUT
PORTABLE. IS THIS MEDICAL SYSTEM
NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED. I
RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
ALLOWING INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICTS REMAIN
FINANCIALLY CHALLENGED BY THE
SCENARIOS. THAT ANY TYPE OF
RELIEF MEDICATION WITHOUT YOUR
HELP IS INEVITABLE THAT THESE
CONTINUE STRAINS. LEAD TO PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICE INSOLVENCY WITHIN
YOUR ROLE COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
SECOND. OF WITNESSED. OF PAUL
GILCHRIST. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN
FOR A LISTENING TEST TODAY- IT
ONLY BE A MATTER OF TIME AND I'M
PAUL GILCHREST I ASSUME THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR ALREADY
COUNTY FIRE AND ICE ON THE
FINANCE COMMITTEE THE ONLY BE A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE RURAL
AGENCIES LIKE COUNTY FIRE WILL
NOT BE PROVIDING FIREFIGHTING
SERVICES FOR TAX REVENUE
RECEIVED NEARLY ALL THE REVENUE
WILL GOING TOWARDS UNFUNDED
ACCRUED LIABILITIES. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN WITHIN ALL
RULE AGENCIES AND DETRIMENTAL TO
THE WELL BEING OF PUBLIC AND
PUBLIC LANDS TO THE PUBLIC IN
PUBLIC LANDS HOUSING AGENCIES
MAINLY FROM- METROPOLITAN AND
URBAN AREAS INCREASING SALES
SIGNIFICANTLY BY HIRING AT
HIGHER WAGES WHICH CONTRIBUTED.
TO INCREASED PENSION COSTS.
THERE COUNTY FIRE THE FIRE
DISTRICT'S ROLE DISTRICTS DO NOT
RECEIVE ANY RECIPROCAL VALUE
OTHER THAN A LIABILITY THAT THEY
HAVE TO PAY FOR SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE NOT GAINING. INCREASE
PENSION LIABILITIES BECAUSE AND-
BECAUSE IMPACTED AGENCIES TO
FACE UNSAFE CONDITIONS FROM OF
FIREFIGHTERS AND PUBLIC. RURAL
AGENCIES ARE BEING FORCED. TO
REDUCE STAFFING FROM THREE OO TO
EITHER TO- ARE ONE HELLO I THREE
OWES AN OSHA STANDARD AND THIS
MEANS THAT- BEING ABLE TO EFFECT
A RESCUE IS CHALLENGING FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND PUTS THEM AT
RISK AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC. THE
IN TRAGICALLY ELDORADO COUNTY
USING VARIOUS LOCAL AGENCIES
REDUCE SERVICES TO STAFFING
LEVELS TO- AND WHAT AND ONE OF.
LEVELS THIS IS TRULY RELATED TO
THE WAY I COSTS THAT ARE HAVING
TO BE- YOUR FIREFIGHTER ARE ABLE
TO FOCUS ON FIRE SUPPRESSION AND
PREVENTION 60% OF ALL WILDFIRES.
ARE OUR STAFF TO OUR RESOURCES
COME FROM THESE A LOCAL AGENCIES
AND SO WE'RE DIMINISHING THOSE
AGENCIES ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO FIGHT WILDFIRES.
EL DORADO COUNTY FARM MAINTAINS
AN AVERAGE OF SEVENTY NINE
CIVILIAN FIREFIGHTER TYPE
PERSONNEL. IN OVER THE PAST FIVE
TO TEN YEARS. WE HAVE HAD
TURNOVER IN THE RATES OF FIFTY
THREE AND HUNDRED SEVENTY
PERSONNEL THAT ARE LEAVING OUR
AGENCY BECAUSE THEY CAN GET PAID
MORE BUT WE GAIN THE BENEFIT YET
WE HAVE TO PAY THE LIABILITIES.
ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL AND
PROVIDE SOME EQUITY FOR- FOR THE
LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT OUR WILD
LANDS IN THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MISTER GILCHREST OF WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO. SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
. IS THERE ANYONE PLEASE STEP UP
AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO- IDENTIFY
YOURSELF IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
MAKEY KAISER MA'AM I AM- WITH
ELDORADO COUNTY FIRE I'M ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS I REPRESENT
THE CITY OF PLACERVILLE. I'M
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND I STRONGLY AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD PASS THIS SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SCENE- NO MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE ROOM- MODERATOR
COULD WE ASK ANY. THE ONE WHO
WOULD OF IS ON THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE TO. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY. PLEASE CALL ON
THEM. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE
IS OPEN. I PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE I AM WAITING THOUGH- ALL
RIGHT OR- WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN
PROGRAM PMI PRESIDENT OF THE HOW
ARE COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIREFIGHTERS. LOCAL THREE FIVE
FIVE SIX I'M THINKING AND THE
PORK. SENATE BILL- OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY- WHICH OVERRIDE MAY BE
RESTRUCTURING OF PENSION
LIABILITY FORMULA AND PROVIDE
EQUITY EMPLOYER PARTICIPATING.
IN A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM- WORLD IS A CRITICAL
PROVIDING A TEMPLE SERVICES NOT
PROVIDED ANOTHER WAVE OF OFFENSE
TO JOIN IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
WILDFIRES ON FEDERAL LAND. HELLO
LOWER FEDERAL. BECAUSE A LOWER
LOWER FUNDING LEVEL SMALL ROLE
AGENCIES OFTEN SERVICE TRAINING
GROUNDS FOR FIREFIGHTERS. WHO
REGULARLY MIGRATE TO
METROPOLITAN IN AFFLUENT AREAS
WERE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS MOSTLY IN
HAND- INCOME IN RETIREMENT
OBLIGATION FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
CURRENT GOVERNMENT CODES REQUIRE
SMALL AGENCIES LIKE MINE- MARC
FORTUNATE PENSION PENSION
OBLIGATIONS ADAM NPREDICTABLE
RATE MEANING THAT. SMALL
AGENCIES NEED TO RESERVE A LARGE
PORTION OF THE MONEY HE BENEFIT
AN EMPLOYEE OF ANOTHER AGENCY.
AND FOR ALL PARK SERVICES TO BE
SUSTAINABLE EQUITY NEEDS TO
OCCUR IN PENSION LIABILITIES SO
THAT MONEY CAN BE COLLECTED AND
EXPANDED IN SUPPORT OF LOCAL
EMERGENCY SERVICES DELIVERY
INCLUDING AN INVESTMENT AND
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS. THE PUBLIC
IN HIS LIABILITIES TO BE
PROPORTIONAL TO THE RATE AT
WHICH PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS.
WERE PAID THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. SO THAT
CONCLUDES SO SUPPORT WITNESSES
ALL RIGHT- WILL COME- BACK TO
OPPOSITION NOW THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. I'VE SEEN NONE OF
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF THE
FOURTEENTH TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO ONE IN HERE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS.
RIGHT I'M I'M ALL MAKE MY OWN-
COMMENTS- I'M NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- WELL
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE AUTHOR ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT RECIPROCITY WAS
BUILT INTO OUR PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
REPUBLICAN POISED TO MOVE FROM
ONE PUBLIC IMPORT TO ANOTHER
WITHOUT FEAR. OF ANY NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THEIR PENSIONS
AND ALSO FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYERS TO
BENEFIT FROM BEING ABLE TO
RECRUIT FROM A STATEWIDE POOL-
OF EXPERIENCED PUBLIC SERVANTS
WHO OTHERWISE MIGHT NEVER LEAVE
THEIR EXISTING EMPLOYER. AND I'M
WORRIED THAT THE BILL WILL
DISRUPT THAT FLEXIBILITY
PRECISELY AT A TIME WHEN MANY
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS. ALREADY FACE
CHALLENGES ATTRACTING STUFF TO
FILL OPEN POSITIONS- I'M I'M
CONCERNED THAT BY CREATING
DIFFERENT TREATMENT. BY A NEW
PUBLIC EMPLOYER BETWEEN JOB
APPLICANTS WERE ALREADY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC RETIREMENT SYSTEM
AND JOB APPLICANTS WERE NOT THE
BILL KRISTOL DISCRIMINATORY
TREATMENT TOWARDS. EXISTING
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. FINALLY THE
BILL'S UNCLEAR HOW ONE WOULD
DETERMINE WHO WOULD DETERMINE. A
WINNER CAUSATIVE EMPLOYER HAD
PROVIDED COMPOSITION IS ABOVE
WHAT WAS REASONABLY EXPECTED.
SUCH OF THE COMPOSITION WOULD
TRIGGER THE EMPLOYER TO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED EMPLOYER FOR
INCREASED PENSION LIABILITY- SO-
JUST WANTED TO. A TO SURE WHERE
I'M AT- ON THE BILL IN. TURN
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
CENTER WHERE. FROM EXCUSE ME THE
CHAIR MADE OF MOST OF THE
COMMENTS I WAS GOING TO MAKE I
WANTED TO IT WE SALUTE THE OFFER
FOR MAKING A RUN AT THIS OUT
BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR YOU'RE
RESPONDING TO YOUR DISTRICT AND
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE- OUR
ISSUES MERMAID ONE OF THE MAIN
PRACTICAL POINTS I WAS GOING TO
MAKE. THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED IS
UP PROVIDING AN EMPLOYEE AN
INCREASE AS THE ANALYSIS SAYS-
THAT- WHEN THE LATER EMPLOYEE
PROVIDES THE EMPLOYED INCREASE
IN COMPENSATION BEYOND WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN REASONABLY
EXPECTED AND AS I WALKED IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS I NEVER SAW A
CLEAR DEFINITION OF REASONABLY
EXPECTED AND I'M SURE. I AM THAT
WALK DEFINITION. AS SOMEBODY IN
THE MID NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHOSE
HARD FOR TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR AND THEN CLOSED OUT MARCH
FIRST FORTY YEARS CREDIT WITH
EIGHT YEARS AS A CABINET
SECRETARY AND- A AND I'M SURE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WAS VERY
BEGRUDGING ABOUT. HAVING TO HAVE
ACTUARIAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHAT MY CABINET SECRETARY.
SALARY WISE NEVER THE LAST IT'S
HE HE I THINK THE INTERESTING
THING TO ME WOULD BE. IS ON THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF RECIPROCITY. HAS
IT ONLY GONE ONE WAY. AS IT ONLY
GONE FROM OF THE FIRE DISTRICT
LOSING PEOPLE THAT GO TO HIGHER
PAID ONES AND THEN. THE EXACT
QUOTE WAS WHAT WAS ANECDOTAL
WASN'T DEMONSTRATED TO ME FACT
RULING BECAUSE IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT THAT FACT IS AN ISSUE
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE CLEARLY
DEMONSTRABLE BY THEIR FAX. MAYBE
AT SOME POINT WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT IT BUT IT'S IT I FIND IT
GOES BACK AND FORTH AND WE HAD
TROUBLE WHEN I WAS MAYOR. OVER
THE FACT THAT WE WERE A LITTLE
COASTAL CITY. AND OVER THE HILL
WAS SENATOR CORTESE'S
JURISDICTION THAT WOULD HIRE
AWAY ARE TRAINED POLICE OFFICERS
FOR THIRTY OR FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE A YEAR AFTER WE
STRUGGLED WITH THEM TO GET
THROUGH THE POST ACADEMY SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT. FORTUNATELY A
LOT OF THEM WANTED TO LIVE BY
THE COAST AND THAT MIGHT
COUNTERBALANCE THE ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE BUT THAT WAS A
DISADVANTAGE AND IT WAS ALSO
TRUE WITH OUR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN THE SANTA CLARA
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. AND OTHER
THINGS SO ARM I RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS MAY WELL BE AN ISSUE I JUST
DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS FULLY
BAKED AND I THINK SOME OF THE
FACTS ARE NOT FULLY IN EVIDENCE
YET AND- I WOULD BE WILLING OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME TO CONTINUE A
CONVERSATION BUT- I'M- GOING TO
VOTE NO ON THE BILL. TODAY I
THINK SOONER LEARN COULD JUST. A
QUICK- I REALLY AM SYMPATHETIC
TO. THE CASE THAT YOU'VE MADE
TODAY IN THE WITNESSES HAVE HAVE
MADE TODAY. I THINK THE HARD
PART FOR ME SOMEONE HAS BEEN
ALLUDED TO HERE. IS THAT THERE'S
A STATEWIDE SYSTEM COVERS
MILLIONS OF WORKERS IN ALL KINDS
OF CLASSIFICATIONS AND JOBS- AND
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
DISTRICTS. AND IT'S HARD TO MAKE
A DECISION THAT WILL IMPACT
POTENTIALLY IMPACT THE WHOLE
STATE. FOR WHAT APPEARED TO BE
SOME YOU KNOW OF SITUATIONS OF
UNFAIRNESS OR GREATER HARDSHIP
SO I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM
TODAY AND I THINK. THIS SHOULD
BE A WAY OF ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
THIS TODAY DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO THAT WHEN
THERE'S ISSUE SEEMS LOPSIDED TO
FIX IT IN THE WAY THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING SO. OKAY SEE NO OTHER-
REQUEST BE RECOGNIZE IT YES
HELLO I WANT. I MAKE CLOTHES AND
I WANTED PERSONAL THANK YOU FOR
THE FOR THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL REALLY
NEEDS IS A LOT. MORE
CONVERSATION AND- SO I MAYBE
IT'S FOR THOSE OF US. WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THIS LINE OF WORK FOR A
LONG TIME. TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR
ME SIXTEEN YEARS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SO I WANT TO SHARE
THEIR THEIR SITUATION AND THIS
THIS IS NOT JUST GERMANE TO.
ELDORADO COUNTY FIRE THIS IT
THIS HAS TO DO WITH COUNTY. THIS
HAS TO DO WITH COUNTY JUST HAS
TO DO A SPECIAL DISTRICTS- ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO. THERE
MAYBE. YOU HAVE YOU'VE HIRED
SOMEBODY YOU'VE TRAINED THEM AND
THEY MAY WORK. TWENTY YEARS VIEW
AND YOU THEIR WAY. THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE ALLOCATED TO EUROPE'S
FIRST FOR YOUR AGENCY WHATEVER
AGENCIES SAY THAT MAYBE MAYBE BE
FIRE MAYBE COUNTY MAY BE A CITY
. AND THEY AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
PAYING IN A PURSE. AND THEN IF
THEY LEAVE YOUR AGENCY AND THEY
GO IN THIS CASE ELDORADO IS NOT
VERY FAR FROM SACRAMENTO AND
SACRAMENTO PAYS A HECK OF A LOT
MORE THAN ELDORADO DOES SO THEY
MAY WORK TWENTY YEARS. AND THEN
THEY GO THE TOP TWO YEARS OF
THEIR PAY THEY GO TO SACRAMENTO
. AND THEY THEIR THEY WENT FROM
FIFTY THOUSAND THIS IS PICKING
NUMBER TWO NINETY. OKAY SO THEY
PAY SO THEN THEY WERE TWO YEARS
IT'S A HARD TOP TWO YEARS OF
YOUR- FIRST THAT YOU GET
CREDITED FOR. BUT BUT THIS
AGENCY THAT AGREED TO PAY FIFTY
THOUSAND AND PUT THE MONEY IN
FOR FIFTY THOUSAND. HAS TO PAY.
ALL THAT TALK TO YEARS BACK FOR
THE RETIREMENT OF THAT PLACE SO
NOW THAT AGENCY THAT WAS
PRUDENT. IN NEGOTIATING WITH
THEIR EMPLOYEES IN GOOD FAITH.
IS PAYING THAT EXTRA AMOUNT THAT
THE ACTUALLY RETIRED OUT FROM
THE OTHER AGENCY. NOW ON TOP OF
THEIR PROBLEM THERE PROP TO
EIGHTEEN THEY CAN'T GO OUT.
WITHOUT A TWO THIRDS VOTE THEY
CAN'T UP THERE. THERE ARE. ABOUT
TO EVEN OFFSET THEIR- OFFSET THE
INCREASES THAT THEY THAT ARE
FORCED UPON THEM BY THE
PERSISTENT. SO IF YOU YOU CAN'T
YOUR KANNST YOU AND YOU HAVE TO
PROVIDE A SERVICE AT THE SAME
TIME. SO WHETHER IT'S A- COUNTY
A CITY APARTMENT HE THESE GUYS
CAN'T PROVIDEA SERVICE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T RAISE THEIR TAX BASE
BECAUSE OF THE CAN YOU TWO
THIRDS VOTE. NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO THEY CAN'T RECRUIT BECAUSE
OUR COMPETING GETS AGENCIES
AROUND THEM. THAT ARE PAYING A
HIGHER WAGE SO. LOOK THIS IS
COMPLICATED AND THIS IS TOUGH
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY. ALL
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA THIS HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. I HAVE SIXTEEN YEARS IN
PERSON MYSELF. IN LASSEN COUNTY
AS A SUPERVISOR. IF I WAS TO GO
TO WORK FOR AGENCY FOR TWO YEARS
LASSEN COUNTY SB ON AT A REALLY
HIGH RATE I MADE LIKE THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS AS A SUPERVISOR
. IF I WENT TO WORK FOR A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
SOMEWHERE FOR TWO YEARS AT IT
EMPATE INTO PERSON. MY COUNTY
HAS TO PICK UP THAT DELTA. SO
THIS IS NOT GERMANE JUST TO MY
LITTLE FIRE TO SECURE CAN'T GET
CAN'T RAISE THE RATE. BECAUSE OF
TWO TO EIGHTEEN PROBLEMS
EVENTUALLY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PAYING OUT ALL THEIR- MONEY TO
THE RETIREES AND THERE'S GONNA
BE NO SERVICE THERE. AND THAT'S
NOT JUST UNIQUE TO ELDORADO
THAT'S THEIR CASE AND THEY-
ACTUALLY OF PEOPLE THAT ARE.
REALLY WIDE AND LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE TO SEE THAT THAT THIS
DOESN'T WORK VERY WELL SO. I
KNOW THIS BILL IS NOT GONNA GET
OUT HERE TODAY BUT I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION AND I'D LIKE TO
ME IN THE BILL. TO DO A STUDY WE
SHOULD LOOK AT HOW WE LOOK AT.
THE FUTURE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU'RE IN ELDORADO
FIRE DISTRICT OR YOU'RE IN. SAN
DIEGO. IT'S IT THERE'S HAS TO BE
SOME EQUITY HERE YOU CAN'T.
FORCE UPON. AGENCY TO PAY
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T WERE ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE FOR. AND YOUR
SERVICE SAY THEY TO GO SHE DID
IT IN MY IN MY CASE THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IF I READ
ENOUGH AYE SPIKE MY RETIREMENT.
BECAUSE I WORK TO YOUR SOMEWHERE
THEY DIDN'T THEN THEY CAN'T. GET
IN THERE STOP TENS OF THOSANDS
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS THESE
OUT THERE THERE'S DRIVING. IS
THAT OUR DENTIST GAMING THE
SYSTEM QUITE FRANKLY THAT THE
MONEY WASN'T PAID IN SO I JUST
WANTED TO BE WHERE IT'S A BIG
PROBLEM AND IT REALLY HURTS WHEN
OUR WHEN OUR STOCK MARKET DIPS.
AND R. PERS LIABILITIES ARE
GONNA SKYROCKET THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN SOON AND I'VE WE'VE%
TALKED ABOUT UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES AND IT'S DO A
DISSERVICE NOT ONLY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPECTING THAT
RETIREMENT WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT
THESE THINGS AND SEE HOW WE CAN.
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY KEEP PROVIDING THE
SERVICES THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
SO I JUST WANNA SHARE THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS A COMPLICATED
STUFF AND IT'S NOT EASY. BUT WE
ARE GOING TO SEE IN RURAL AREAS-
YOU KNOW. THE LOSS OF HER. HE'S
HE'S GONNA. YEAH WHY DON'T THEY
ALREADY HAVE YOU IS GONNA MAKE A
MOTION FOR MY BILL RIGHT NOW.
BUT YES SENATOR. THERE'S NO SUCH
CENTER SERVICE CENTER NEW. JUST
AS OPPOSED POINT OF ORDER CENTER
NEW THIS IS US BE RECOGNIZED A
DON'T THINK IS- THE
PARLIAMENTARY PROCEDURE HE'S
CONSIDERING YOUR REQUIRES- A
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION OF
HIM UNDERSTAND HIS INTENTION
PROPERLY SO. WE IF WE DON'T KNOW
MEANS THE BILL WOULD JUST CHARGE
RIGHT YEAH I THOUGHT YOU SAID
YOU WERE ALL WE CAN HEAR IT ON
THE ON THE- POSTED ON. MAKING IT
SEVENTY. RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE I
THINK THE PROBLEM IS WE DON'T
HAVE A LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
CORRESPOND TO YOUR MOTION- YOU
KNOW FOR THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
FOR THE RECORD FOR THE COMMITTEE
WOULD TO RELY UPON- SO. THEN IT
IS THE ONLY OPTION THERE'S- ALSO.
NO WE DON'T WE DON'T TERM SO
FIRST OF ALL LET ME LET'S GET
BACK TO MORE MATURE CEDAR IN AND
IT JUST BEFORE I DO LET ME JUST
SAY SINCE THERE WON'T BE IT THE
POSSIBLE BE EMOTIONAL SUPPORT-
IF. AT ALL HERE- I DO I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY. IN TERMS OF THE-
THE CALL FOR AWARENESS THAT- IN
IT WITH RESPECT TO CENTER LARGE
COMMENTS I SERVED ON. SAN JOSE
THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN THE
STATE. I SERVED ON BOTH OF THEIR
PENSION BOARDS- IN A CERTAIN THE
POLICE AND FIRE RETIREMENT BOARD
FOR EIGHT STRAIGHT YEARS YOU
KNOW BY THE- END IN IT WAS A IT
WAS A TRIP IT WAS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND WITH SAN JOSE.
ON THEIR OWN INITIATIVE. DID BY
REFERENDUM- WENT ABOUT TRYING TO
DIVEST OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS AND OTHERS I THOUGHT
THAT- BUT WHEN THEY DID THAT.
ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO HAD COME IN
FROM SANTA CRUZ TO SAN JOSE WENT
FLEEING BACKS IT DOES GO IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION- IN SALES THEY
HAD TO START PICKING UP THOSE
SALARIES. FOR PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
GOING ALL THE BAY AREA AND ALL
OVER THE STATE SO. IT IS
COMPLICATED THERE'S- A DISK
RIPPLE EFFECT CASCADING EFFECT I
WOULD SAY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
WORRY SIR FOR. TWENTY YEARS IF
THERE ARE. ARE INTO. THAT
MOVEMENT- ENTER INTO IN ORDER TO
BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS IN THEIR
OWN CONTRIBUTIONS. THEN THAT'S A
HUGE ERROR WENT INTO MISSION ON
THEIR PART YOU KNOW THIS THIS
ISN'T. THIS ISN'T SURPRISING NEW
COSTS THAT COME UP YEAR BY YEAR
THESE ARE. THE EXTRAPOLATED OUT
IN. YOU KNOW I INSULT IN THE
CIRCLE AT. WE SHOULDN'T BE
ENGAGING IN DEBATE HERE BUT I
JUST WANT YOUKNOW I THINK I'M
QUALIFIED. YOU KNOW TO ENGAGE IN
A DEBATE WHERE WE DO. SO I TO DO
THAT I DO LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO
GO TO CREATE. A STUDY OR SOME
INTEREST IN SOME BALANCE. MAYBE
MAYBE. AFTER YOU START MOVING
THINGS AROUND HYPOTHETICALLY IN
A STUDY REALIZE THERE'S A LITTLE
BETTER WAY TO DO IT WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT HERE AND THAT'S
ALL I WAS TRYING TO SAY IN MY
REMARKS WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
FRAMEWORK IN MY- HUMBLE OPINION-
TO PROCEED TODAY. BUT IF I COULD
JUST TO SAY SUSPENDED ALREADY I
WOULD I. HAD A MOVE THIS. IF.
AMENDED TO PROVIDE FOR STARTED
IN TWO OF THE PURSUE. THAT
POSSIBLE. SO MUCH IS THERE. WELL
I FIVE EIGHT- THAT'S FINE- I
JUST WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
IN INTO THINGS I LOOK I'M- I'M
GONNA WORK ON THIS I THINK I. NO
ONE WE NEED PARITY SOME.
WOULDN'T HAVE PARITY AND WHAT
THINK WE HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
OUR- EMPLOYEES THAT. THAT THERE
IS A RISK. THAT THE RISK IS THAT
IF THESE GUYS GO OUT OF
BUSINESS. AND THEY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE MEANS TO CREATE A PURSE
AND IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED. IN THE
LITTLE TOWN OF LOYALTON FOR THE
FIRST TIME. IN HISTORY OUR STATE
WE HAD THIS HAPPEN WHERE THE
CITY WENT BANKRUPT. AND THE LADY
THAT WAS AT WORK FOR THE CITY
FOR FOREVER AND PAID INTO PERSON
WAS GETTING. LIKE SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AND SHE WENT TO
NINETEEN THOUSAND COULD THERE
JUST WAS NO MONEY SHE BASICALLY
IT TURNS INTO THEIR THEIR THE
DEFINED BENEFIT WENT AWAY. AND
SO. THAT COULD HAPPEN IN THE END
IT COULD HAPPEN REALLY FAST WHEN
THE WHEN THE MARKET CHANGES IN
THESE. LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO PUT THE MONEY AND
THERE'S NO MONEY THERE. SO LOOK
THESE THIS IS REALLY COMPLICATED
STUFF I GET THAT I WILL BE BACK.
I APPRECIATE I JUST I'M GLAD YOU
LISTEN TO THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT EASY. BUT IT
ALSO IS A PROBLEM YOU THERE
COULD. AND IT'S NOT JUST. THE I
MEAN IT HAPPENED. REAL IT THEY
THEY BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION AND
BUT MOST AGENCIES ARE THINK THAT
SOMEBODY ELSE IS GONNA TAKE CARE
OF IT. LATER ON DOWN THE ROAD.
IT'S NOT TRUE THOUGH IS THAT WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES
SO I JUST APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE. I KNOW THAT WE GOTTA.
PROBABLY SAW ME WAITING IN LINE
BUT- I JUST WE'LL BE BACK WE'LL
DO SOME SORT OF A STUDY OR
SOMETHING THAT GIVES US SOME
ACTUARIES WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THESE AGENCIES
AND MAYBE COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT THERE'S A TIERED
SYSTEM OR SOMETHING. GOING INTO
IT SO THAT YOU KNOW. THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PAY THAT. YOU HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY THE
BILL BECAUSE YOU REALLY. ALL THE
YEARS YOU SERVED AT YOUR LOCAL
AGENCY. THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE
EXPECTING TO GET WAS WHAT THE-
WHAT THE SALARY WAS THERE. NOT
TO. SPIKE SALARY. FROM A
DIFFERENT AGENCY. AND IT'S NOT
FAIR TO THE- AGENCY THAT. THAT
YOU WORK FOR BEFORE. WE HAVE TO
PICK UP. AGAIN WE APPRECIATE. I
THE INTENT OF LOOKING AT IT
ACTUALLY I DON'T HIGHVELD. WE
APPRECIATE THAT REQUEST. WE
DON'T HAVE EMOTIONAL. WE DON'T
EMOTIONAL DEPRIVE MAKE WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE A MOTION. WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE A MOTION- ON THE BILL
TO MOVE THE BILL M. AS
PRESENTED- WE CAN'T- WHAT WEEK
WITH A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS ESSENTIALLY-
INEFFECTUAL BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYMORE. SENATE HEARINGS
FOR SENATE BILLS SO
RECONSIDERING HERE- WOULD WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO BE SET BASICALLY
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING IN
PRINT. OF ALONG THE LINES OF
CENTER NEWMAN'S GENEROUS OFFER-
YOU KNOW TO MOVE. AN ALTERNATIVE
SUCH AS A STUDY BILL AND
OBVIOUSLY YOUR IS NOT AS MUCH
EXCERPTED SPURTING PROCEDURE IS
I AM OR BEYOND SO PERHAPS
THERE'S ANOTHER VEHICLE FOR YOU
TO. A TO TAKE THAT STUDY IDEA
AND- AND MOVED ALONG SOME HELP
BUT- THANK YOU FOR ELEVATING THE
ISSUE AND WE APPRECIATE BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. YES CENTER
DRAWS OF. I JUST THEM MAYBE
THERE IS SOME. SHORT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS BOTH
CENTER CORTESE'S CHAIR OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE AND MYSELF WHO
CARES THE SUBPHYLUM. OVER
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS- WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO BRAINSTORM A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW TO BRING IT TO THE
ATTENTION. AND SEE IF THERE'S
SOME WAY SHORT OF LEGISLATION
THAT WE CAN. KEEP MOVING THE
CONVERSATION THIS IS CERTAINLY
THE POTENTIAL FOR INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS LATER IN THE YEAR- YOU
KNOW IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
VEHICLE FOR BRINGING REPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE GOING TO
CALL ON SENATOR LIMÓN AT THIS
TIME. ON SB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
CENTER WHENEVER YOUR SITUATION
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR HIM THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR ON
GOING FEEDBACK ON THIS MEASURE
AS IS EVIDENCED IN THE ANALYSIS
AND A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES THIS
IS DEFINITELY A WORK IN PROGRESS
BILL. ACCORDING TO RECENT
ANALYSIS OF PAY DATA CALIFORNIA
WOMEN IN TWENTY TWENTY LOSS
FORTY SIX BILLION DUE TO THE
GENDER PAY GAP AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND THE STATE LOST SIXTY
ONE BILLION DUE TO THE RACE PAY
GAP. THIS DISPARITY IN WAGE GAP
IS ALSO REFLECTED IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM WHEN THE
AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGE IS CAC. FOR
PURPOSES OF DISA PAYMENTS. UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW THESE BENEFITS
ARE BASED ON THE INDIVIDUAL
WORKER SALARY. SINCE THERE IS A
WELL DOCUMENTED GENDER PAY GAP
WOMEN EMPLOYEES RECEIVE LOWER
BENEFITS THAN THEIR WHITE MALE
COUNTERPARTS. SB FIFTEEN FORTY
EIGHT IS AN ATTEMPT TO NARROW
THE DESPITE THE TO NARROW THE
DISPARITY IN THIS AREA BY
REQUIRING THE AVERAGE WEEKLY
WAGE TO BE INCREASED BY THE
PERCENTAGE OF DISPARITY. IN
EARNINGS BETWEEN GENDER IF THE
APPLICANTS AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGE
IS LESS THAN THAT OF THE
OPPOSITE GENDER. FOR EMPLOYERS
WITH OVER A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
THIS CORRECTION COULD BE BASED
ON DATA REPORTED BY THE EMPLOYER
IN ITS DATA REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. IN ITS FIRST PAY
DATA REPORT. THE DFB H. FOUND
THAT WOMEN WERE WOEFULLY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THE LOWEST PAY
BANDS. FOR EMPLOYERS THAT ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO SUBMIT PAY DATA
REPORTS THEN THE AVERAGE WEEKLY
WAGES INCREASED BY THE
PERCENTAGE OF DISPARITY AND
EARNING BETWEEN GENDERS AS
REPORTED. BY THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STATISTICS.
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
APPLY TO INJURIES OCCURRING ON
OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. CORRECTING THE PAY
GAP THROUGH WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS IS A NECESSARY STEP TO
INSURE OUR WORKERS ARE
COMPENSATED APPROPRIATELY IF
THEY ARE INJURED AT WORK. IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS OF THIS BILL IT HAS
BECOME EVIDENT THAT THERE IS NO
DISPUTE THAT THE PAY. GAP EXIST
BUT HOW WE NAVIGATE THIS COMPLEX
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM TO
ACHIEVE THE INTENDED GOAL OF
HELPING INJURED WORKERS WHO ARE
RECEIVING LESS WORKERS COMP
BENEFITS. JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
WOMEN IS DIFFICULT. AS A RESULT
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION
AND ON IMPLEMENTATION THAT WILL
BE FLUSHED OUT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. OUT TODAY
WE HAVE JASON MARKETS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S APPLICANT
TOURNEY'S ASSOCIATION AND JESSE
GREWAL REPRESENTING UFCW TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER AND WE
WILL TURN TO JASON MARCUS- IF
JASON'S AVAILABLE- I BELIEVE ON
THE COASTLINE YOU MAY HOPE YOU
MAY GO IN PROCEEDS TIME. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN MY NAMEIS JASON MARCUS I
IN THE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. GROUP OF ATTORNEYS
IN CALIFORNIA PROBABLY REPRESENT
OUR INJURED WORKERS AND I
CURRENTLY CHAIR ARE A
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. FROM
CENTER TO THE MON IT IS
UNDISPUTED THAT A WAGE GAP
EXISTS BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN
THIS WAGE GAP EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED BETWEEN WHITE MEN AD
WOMEN OF COLOR. IN ASSEMBLY MON
TESTIFIED SINCE WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS ARE BASED
ENTIRELY ON THE INJURED WORKERS
WAGES THOSE BENEFITS ARE AS A
MATTER OF LAW LOWER FOR WOMEN.
THAN THEY ARE FOR MEN WHAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU IS WHAT WE
CONSIDER TO BE A STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL BY TAKING WASTE OF THIS
CALL BY EITHER THE FEDERAL OR
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT. WE
ARE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE WAGE
GAP FOR LITERALLY HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS THIS DATA IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THE
WEBSITE AND IS READILY
ACCESSIBLE. THE OPPOSITION TO
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT THIS
BILL IS TOO COMPLICATED AND THEN
IT WILL RESULT IN DELAYS IN
PROCESSING CLAIMS. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THIS TO BE TRUE THIS
BILL DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE
EXISTING LAW- THAT ALL WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS MUST BE
REVIEWED AND ACCEPTED OR DENIED
WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF THE FILING
OF A CLAIM- THIS BILL SIMPLY
ADDS ONE ADDITIONAL FACTOR TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE CALCULATION OF
THE WORKERS WAGED. A CALCULATION
THAT INSURANCE CARRIERS ALREADY
PERFORM IN EVERY SINGLE. THE
OFFICE ALSO STATED CONCERNS THAT
THE BRIDE NATURE OF THE-
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED FEDERAL AND
STATE. DATABASES WE DID TAKE
THOSE CONCERNS TO HEART AND
OFFERED AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD-
INSTEAD CREATE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION TO THE WAGE GAP- AND
THEREFORE CLOSE IT AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION- THAT WOULD BE A
TWELVE PERCENT. PAY BUMP FOR
WOMEN BASED ON THE MOST CURRENT
DATA AVAILABLE FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. THAT SHOWS
THAT WOMEN ON AVERAGE EARN 12%
LESS THAN MEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY RATHER THAN WORK
WITH US ON THOSE AMENDMENTS WE
WERE TOLD THAT THOSE MINUTES
WERE NOT ACCEPTABLE AND IT'S
AMENDED THE BILL WOULD BE PLACED
ON THE- CHAMBER OF COMMERCE'S
JOB KILLER LIST. WE FIND A LACK
OF CORPORATION FRUSTRATING. WHAT
WE DO BELIEVE AS A JOB KILLER IS
STAGNANT PERMANENT DISABILITY
BENEFITS THAT HAVE NOT KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION. AND THE FACT
THAT WOMEN CONTINUE TO BE PAID
LESS THAN MALE THEN THERE MAY
COUNTERPARTS. EVEN WHEN THEY GET
INJURED THE JOB. WE RESPECT ASK
FOR AND VOTE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR TEST. WILL MOVE ON TO-
JEFF GREW WHOSE HERE IN THE ROOM
. I GOT MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY OF
THE- MY NAME IS JESSE GRAY WHILE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATE COUNCIL.
HERE ON BEHALF OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS. TESTIFY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN. EIGHT AND THANK
SENATOR LIMÓN FOR AUTHORING THIS
MPORTANT MEASURE. AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE SENATOR AND THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS IT IS
UNDISPUTED THAT THE WAGE GAP
EXISTS BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS IS OF PARTICULAR INTEREST
TO UFCW BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AS A RESULT WAGE
DISPARITIES THAT IMPACT WOMEN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE A DISPARITY
IMPACT ON OUR MEMBERSHIP. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY THE FACT
THAT WOMEN RECEIVE LOWER WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS. THAN
THEIR MALE CO WORKERS BECAUSE OF
THE INEQUALITY WAGE AS- WE KNOW
FIRST HAND THAT WOMEN RECEIVE
LOWER WAGES LESS FREQUENT
PROMOTIONS. AND OFTEN LESS
FAVORABLE CHEFS OR ASSIGNMENTS.
SINCE BENEFITS ARE BASED ON
WAGES IT IS POSSIBLE FOR A
FEMALE WORKER TO RECEIVE LAST
WORKER COMPENSATION BENEFITS.
THAN A MALE CO WORKER WITH A
SIMILAR POSITION TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE YOU HAS A SIMILAR
WORKPLACE INJURY. WELL YOU SEE
W. MEMBERS WORK THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AS ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE
WORKERS. WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT INJURED WORKERS
PARTICULARLY WOMEN BE GRANTED
EQUITABLE WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS. IS FOR THESE REASONS
AND MORE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
THAT CONCLUDES LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS ITS
SUPPORT POSITION ON SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSION DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. ON SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM SEEN NONE OF LOS MODERATOR
TO CHECK THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT A PLEASE LET US KNOW
THE NUMBER. EIGHT POSTED FAVOR
OF SB ONE FOUR. EIGHT FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
START. THOSE IN FAVOR OF SB ONE
FOUR FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
WHAT AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
COREY PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU.
LIVE ONE WATCH YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. THE BOARD OF- THE L. ARE WITH
THE ONLY TRACE- IT'S JUST
GROWING COMPETITION LOCAL.
TWENTY TWO- THANK YOU THURS- NO
ONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR WILL MOVE ON. PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK NOW TO
THE OPPOSITION SIDE. AND WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SOME OF THE CALLING
ASHLEY HOFFMAN FIRST TO A BLUES
HERE IN PERSON. ACTUALLY PAID
FOR JUST NINETY GOING FIRST I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL WELCOME JAVA IN OUR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS EMPHATICALLY AGREED
WITH THE SENTIMENT OF THE
QUALITY IN ALL ASPECTS OF
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING WORKERS
COMPENSATION. THIS BILL IS AN
ABUSE OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IT WILL
DRIVE AND LESS AMOUNT OF
LITIGATION WHICH DIVERT LIMITED
PUBLIC DOLLARS AWAY FROM THOSE
WHO RELY ON ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES. AND IT WILL ULTIMATELY
DELAY BENEFITS FOR ALL GENDERS
OF WORKERS WHO DESPERATELY NEED
THEM WHEN THEIR CLAIM IS
LITIGATED. THIS IS AN THERE'S
NOT MUCH THAT SIMPLE AND THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE CURRENT
CALCULATION FOR TEMPORARY AND
PERMANENT DISABILITY IS BECAUSE
IT'S BASED ON A SIMPLE FORMULA
OF ACTUAL WE JUST LOST. THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT IN AN EVEN
MORE COMPLEX WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY AT A LAWSUIT TO
EVERY CLAIM WHICH WOULD
ULTIMATELY BIRD AN INJURED
WORKER SEEKING QUICK RESOLUTION
TO THEIR CLAIM. AND A
DEMONSTRATION OF A QUALITY THE
SAME FORMULAS ARE USED FOR ALL
GENDERS AND THERE IS NO
ADJUSTMENT. FOR RATES BASED UPON
THE GENDER OF AN INJURED WORKER.
SOME ADDITIONAL CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL IS THIS BILL DOES NOT
SPECIFY THAT THE PROPOSED
EARNING COMPARISON IS WITHIN THE
SAME EMPLOYER RATHER IT REFERS
TO A COLLECTION OF SOME
EMPLOYERS NATIONALLY. WHO'S
DATED DOES NOT CONSIDER REGIONAL
RATES OF PAY OR THE EMPLOYER'S
OWN PAY STRUCTURES FOR WHICH
MANY PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARE
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED OR
DETERMINED BASED ON OTHER
FACTORS THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
CLAIMS ADMINISTRATORS KNOWLEDGE.
SUCH AS LENGTH OF SERVICE
CERTIFICATIONS AND EDUCATION.
AUTOMATICALLY INCREASING TAX
FREE WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS WITHOUT ANY CHANGES TO
ACTUAL WAGES WILL CREATE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR WOMEN TO RETURN
TO THE WORK FORCE. AND ASKING
CLAIMS ADMINISTRATORS TO MAKE
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHAT A
WOMAN'S RATE OF PAY SHOULD BE
MAY BE WELL INTENTIONED BUT IT
IS INHERENTLY DISCRIMINATORY TO
OTHER GENDER EXPRESSIONS AND
IDENTITIES. AND WE'LL SUBJECT
EMPLOYERS TO ALL MAY OF JUST.
LAWSUIT SINCE THEY ARE BASING A
BENEFIT ON SOMEONE'S GENDER
ALTERNATELY WERE CONCERNED THAT
THE BILL WILL FOSTER INCREASED
AND UNNECESSARY LITIGATION WHICH
DRIVE UPS CLAIMS COSTS. AND
ULTIMATELY NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
INJURED WORKERS OF ALL GENDERS
FOR THESE REASONS WERE STRONGLY
OPPOSED YOU PLEASE RESTATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION WE GOT OUR
ORDER. YES FAITH FOR JUST THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OKAY I
THOUGHT THAT WAS I THOUGHT THAT
WAS IT. THANK YOU. THE CALPERS
WERE TRANSITION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES GROW OKAY THANK YOU
. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THE
MOTIVE. A GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT STATED PREVIOUSLY THIS
BILL WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
INCREASE WORKERS COMP BENEFITS
BY THE AVERAGE DIFFERENCE IN
EARNINGS BETWEEN GENDER EITHER
AS REPORTED IN THE EMPLOYERS
DEFEATS REPORT OR SECOND
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL AVERAGE
DATA. SET FORTH BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STATISTICS
FOR SMALLER COMPANIES OR
ENTITIES WHO DO NOT FILE THESE
REPORTS THIS MEANS THOSE
AUTOMATIC INCREASES WOULD BE
DICTATED BY NATIONAL AVERAGE
DATA THAT DOES NOT HAVE ANY
RELATIONSHIP TO THAT COMPANY AT
ALL OR THAT PUBLIC ENTITY. FOR
THOSE WHO FILED IF EACH REPORTS
THIS DEFUSE REPORTS PROVIDE A
BROAD SNAPSHOT OF A MOMENT IN
TIME OF WHERE WORKERS FALL INTO
TEN BROAD JOB CATEGORIES AND
BRAD PAISLEY AND WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT AVERAGE SHOULD BE
USED AS A BASIS FOR THESE
AUTOMATIC INCREASES- AND I DO
WANT TO TAKE A SECOND TO ADDRESS
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ADDRESS
VI<c.cyan> AT SUPPORT WITNESS- YES IT</c>
IS TRUE THAT WE DID BELIEVE THAT
THOSE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ACTUALLY WERE MORE PROBLEMATIC.
AND IN THE BILL THAT WAS IN
PRINT AND IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
AGREED WITH THAT ASSESSMENT AS
WELL AND WE DID HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT AN AUTOMATIC 12% INCREASE
FOR EVERY- FEMALE INJURED WORKER
WOULD POTENTIALLY RUN AFOUL OF
THE EQUAL PROTECTION LAW THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION- AGAIN HAD
CONCERNS THAT THIS IS BASED ON A
NATIONAL AVERAGE IT HAS NO TIRE
RELATIONSHIP TO THE COMPANY. AND
WOULD EFFECTIVELY REQUIRE THE-
WORKERS COMP APPEALS BOARD- TO
NOW ALSO HAVE JURISDICTION
BASICALLY HAVE TO HOLD AND MANY-
TRIAL. FOR EVERY SINGLE. IN
ORDER TO HAVE ANY CHANCE OF
PUSHING BY AGAINST PERCEPTION.
I'M SO FOR THOSE WHO. I OR A NO
VOTE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
ARE GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
ROOM ITSELF FOR ANYONE ELSE SO
PLEASE COME ON FORWARD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHRISTOPHER KELLY ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CLAIMS PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE CHAMBER THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE ELSE
COMING FORWARD A MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION HE
FOURTEENTH. EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS PREFERRED COULD OFTEN BE
HAVE A PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHENEVER YOU GO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE HEALTHIER
HOSPITALS THAT THE STATE ONE OF
THE COMMENTS FROM BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES ASHLEY HOFFMAN IT
BEFORE IT IN RESPECT POPULATION.
HE. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR-
WE ARE GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- LET ME JUST START OFF
AND THEN- RECOGNIZE ANY OTHERS-
TO THE AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR OF
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THE BILL'S
WORK IN PROGRESS IT WAS
CERTAINLY- THE SENTIMENT OF. THE
COMMITTEE ITSELF- I SUSPECT-
PERHAPS SOME SOME MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL. BESIDES
MYSELF- THAT SAID- HERE I AM NOT
NECESSARILY TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THE OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY
THE OPPOSITION MADE A RAISE SOME
SOME SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT
WE NEED TO BE ADDRESSED GOING
FORWARD I THINK- BUT- IT JUST
JUST STATING. ONE OF THE ISSUES
IN TERMS OF FOR THE FRAME. IF
NOT THE METRICS OF THE BILL-
ALLOWING EMPLOYERS SOMEHOW- TO
JUSTIFY DIFFERENTIALS THAT DON'T
HAVE TO DO WITH WITH INOTES PAY
EQUITY ISSUES AS AS AS SORT OF
AS YOU PRESENTED- AND I THINK AS
AS I UNDERSTAND THEM- THERE ARE
CERTAINLY. SITUATIONS WHERE
WE'RE DIFFERENTIALS MIGHT BE THE
DRIVING FACTOR A BONA FIDE
ACCEPTED STRUCTURED COULD EVEN
BE STEP ORIENTED DIFFERENTIALS
THAT PEOPLE ARE WORKING THROUGH
IN AND SOMEHOW THERE HAS TO BE A
WAY NOT TO GET CAUGHT UP IN THAT
IS WHAT THAT AS AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT- THAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT YOU THINK OF. A
COMMITTEE STUFF IS BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT AS WELL- IN IN.
WELL IF YOU DON'T IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE THE IMPETUS OF- YOU KNOW
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION. FOLKS
ON IN ON ALL SIDES COMING
FORWARD TO ELEVATE THIS ISSUE OF
EQUITY- OBVIOUSLY NON WORKERS
COMP ISSUES. PUT YOU INTO IT SO
SIGNIFICANTLY IT'S YOU KNOW I'M
STATING THE OBVIOUS- JUST WAGES
BENEFITS- IN GENERAL SO SOMEHOW-
I GUESS I'M NOT NECESSARILY
PUTTING OUT THE CHALLENGE OF FOR
ONE AUTHORED TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
ALL OF THAT AT ONCE- IN TERMS OF
A RE FRAMING OR RESTRUCTURING-
BUT IT CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE.
ADDRESS THE WAY I LOOK AT THE
BILL- SO- IT'S- SB PUTS ME IN
THE POSITION REALLY OF AGAIN
HEARING YOU SAY THAT YOUR
RECOGNIZE- THE WORK IN PROGRESS
NATURE OF THINGS TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE THE WORK IN
PROGRESS- YOU KNOW I WILL EXTEND
WHAT I WOULD CHARACTERIZE AS A
COURTESY I BUILT MYSELF READING
TO GO FURTHER ALONG- THE BILL AS
IN PRINT IS NOT SOMETHING I
WOULD SUPPORT LATER ON- BUT
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN YOU CAN MANAGE
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IN A IN A VERY PRODUCTIVE
WAY- BE ON THIS COMMITTEE- SO
WITH THAT SAID I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE- OTHERS- ON. ON OUR
COMMITTEE HERE CENTER DRAWS A
YES- BECAUSE I KNOW HIM AND I
KNOW WE WANT. EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR- JUST TO GIVE
AN IS AN EXAMPLE I HAVE A BILL
ON WHICH REPLENISHMENT ON PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND DISABILITY AND
BECAUSE WE KNOW THATTHE LOWER
INCOME ARE PRIMARILY WOMEN. AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR SO TO INCREASE
THAT WHICH REPLENISHMENT A WOULD
DO A LOT THAT DOESN'T EXACTLY
MORE DIRECTLY SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS A GENDER- PAY INEQUITIES
BUT IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF I THINK
WHAT WORLD TRYING TO DO TOGETHER
SO I TO WILL EXTEND. AN AYE VOTE
TODAY BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
ALL ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT THING
FOR WOMEN. AND- I'M TRYING TO
THINK OF ALL THE- THE REASONS OF
WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO
WOMEN- WE KEEP GETTING. YOU KNOW
THE SHORT END WHEN IT COMES TO
RETIREMENT SICK YOU YOU NAME IT
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE ISSUE IN
WHICH WOMEN ARE NOT- GET THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK. SO KEEP
WORKING AT IT- I SUPORT YOU-
AND I HOPE WE GET THERE. IN
ORDER FOR THANK YOU- IT'S EASY
TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE OF THE TWO
PREVIOUS NUMBERS BECAUSE I THINK
IN PARTICULAR THE GOAL HERE IS-
ONE THAT WE STRONGLY AGREE ON
IT'S QUESTION OF THE BILL
ALIGNING WITH THE GOAL. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT A CENTER
CORTESE WAS ADDRESSING AND
GIVING YOU THE CHANCE TO DO THAT
TO HAVE THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL
ON AND- USE THAT THROUGH ME.
YESTERDAY ANOTHER COMMITTEE I
THINK TWICE ASKING PEOPLE WHEN
IT WAS SAID THAT IT WAS A WORK
IN PROGRESS WHAT THEIR PLAN WAS
THE TWO ND BEING A WORK IN
PROGRESS I THOUGHT MAYBE. I
WOULD ASK IT HOW DO YOU SEE
GOING FROM HERE TO WORK SOME OF
THESE THINGS OUR DAY IN THE
HOPES THAT THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
THE ISSUE. WELL IT A THINK WE'LL
CONTINUE THAT TO KIND OF LOOK
WORK ONE WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
YOU KNOW HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE IF
THERE'S NOT A BILL THERE'S NOT A
CONVERSATION AND SO FOR DECADES
AS HAS BEEN STATED WE KNOW AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WHETHER IT'S
BENEFITS WHETHER IT'S RETIREMENT
WHETHER IT'S SALARIES. THERE'S A
DISCREPANCY AND I THINK THERE'S
REALLY ONLY A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE
THAT HAPPENED YOU KNOW IT TO BE
WOMEN IN THE LEGISLATURE SCARING
THESE BILLS- TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE'S A SYSTEMIC WAY TO
CHANGE IT SO TRUTHFULLY I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE COMMITTEE
ONE STEP AT A TIME AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR THOUGHT LEADERS
ARE CHAIRS ARE COMMITTEES. AT TO
FIGURE OUT A PATH- WHETHER THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY-
WHETHER IT MOVES FORWARD YOU
KNOW BY THE END OF AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST I THINK IT'S STILL NEEDS
TO BE A CONVERSATION AND WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS OR INPUT I
AM GETTING GET NO WORK SO MY
PATHWAY IS TO START HERE. AND
SEE HOW FAR I CAN GET A AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WHETHER IT MAKES
IT OUT THIS YEAR OR YOU KNOW IN
FUTURE YEARS WE WILL HAVE. A
RECORD OF WHAT THE ANALYSIS AND
HISTORY AND IS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE IT I MEAN THEY
THE DISCREPANCY AND THE GAPS
AREN'T GOING AWAY AND I THINK
THE OTHER PIECE THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE IS THAT
WHILE WE TRY TO ADVANCE SOME OF
THIS YOU KNOW- IN PARTICULAR
WITH THE OPPOSITION WHILE
THERE'S A RECOGNITION. THAT
THERE'S AN ISSUE THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF SALUTE SINCE BEING
BROUGHT THE T. AND SO I. FEEL
THE RESPONSIBILITY- YOU KNOW AS
A WOMAN OF COLOR IS A LOT THE
NAFCU YOU KNOW IN THE STATE. YOU
KNOW. STATISTICALLY LETTING US
GET FORTY CENTS SOMETHING CENTS
TO THE DOLLAR RIGHT TO THE MIGHT
AND- TO SAY HEY. THIS SHOULD BE
BROUGHT UP BECAUSE IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING IN THE
SALARIES ARE GETTING IT. YOU
KNOW IN OTHER PLACES AND SO FOR
ME IT'S ABOUT BRINGING FORWARD
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS AND TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER THEY'RE GOING
TO MAKE IT OR NOT- THIS IS ONE
SO YOU KNOW ONE POSSIBLE
SOLUTION. MAY NOT MAKE IT ALL
THE WAY- BUT IT ALSO. I THINK
CONTRIBUTES TO THE OVERALL
CONVERSATION WHAT CAN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DO. TO TRY TO INCH
FORWARD ON SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
BROADLY RECOGNIZED. AS A FORTY
FIFTY SIXTY YEAR. PROBLEM SO
THAT IS MY ANSWER. RIGHT WELL
AND IT'S A GOOD ONE THANK YOU
FOR. YES SO THANK YOU BOTH- YES
- WITH WERE CONSIDERED ROSES ARE
OFFERED TO MOVE THE BILL BUT
WILL CONTINUE- AND THEY COME
BACK TO CENTER DRAWS WITH A
PLEASURE SO I'M THE ONLY ONE I.
HAVE THE HIGHEST AND VERY VERY
FOND- I THINK YOU'RE AN AMAZING
AND BEAUTIFUL WOMAN ON SO MANY
LEVELS- SO I WANT YOU TO TAKE
THIS IN THE MOST- RESPECTFUL AND
CORDIAL- WAY BUT- I DO HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL AND
PRINCIPLE- SB FIFTY FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOR THE RECORD. UNDER THIS
SPELL. TWO SIMILARLY INJURED
WORKERS COULD RECEIVE DIFFERENT
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER. TO BASE
AN INJURED WORKER'S DISABILITY
PAYMENT IN HIS OR HER GENDER IS
UNFAIR AND DISCRIMINATORY. IT
ALSO VIOLATES THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE US
CONSTITUTION. I WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
CONSIDER THE WORK OF THE LATE
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG MOST
NOTABLY HER WORK REPRESENTING
CHARLES MORITZ. A MAN WHO WAS
CARING FOR HIS ELDERLY MOTHER
THAT HAD BEEN DENIED CARE GIVING
TAX DEDUCTION BECAUSE HE WAS AN
UNMARRIED MAN. JUSTICE GINSBURG
UNDERSTOOD THAT DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF SEX REGARDLESS
ABOUT SEX HARMS EVERYONE. THREE
QUALITY WILL NOT BE BORN OUT OF
FURTHER INEQUALITY AND FOR THESE
REASONS I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL- AT THIS TIME AND I DO
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO RECONSIDER
THEIR VOTE AND VOTE NO. BUT I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE BILL
AS IT INVOLVED IN IS YOU WORK
FOR BECAUSE I DO YOU KNOW. THAT
YOUR INTENT IS ALWAYS ABOUT
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND MOVING
THE NEEDLE FORWARD SO ON THAT
PRINCIPLE I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
SEE HOW THIS BILL INVOLVES AND
WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO ON THIS
FRONT SO- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
AND NO OFFENSE TAKEN AND IT'S
ACTUALLY THAT EXACT SAME VALUE
OF DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN
THAT IS NOT PROTECTED WHERE WE
START WITH WAGES SO THE GOOD
NEWS IS I HAVE A WAGE BILL AS
WELL. THAT ADDRESSES THIS
DISCRIMINATION OF PEACE AND SO
IT IS A PROBLEM WHEN WOMEN SO
THIS IS ABOUT WORKERS COMP AND
HISTORY. RATE OF WOMEN NOT.
BEING PAID WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
PAID THEIR FOR THEIR WORKERS
COMP IS ALSO INSUFFICIENT WELL
THERE IS A BILL AT TO GET MORE
INFORMATION AND DATA IN TERMS OF
WHAT THAT PAGE GET. THAT WAGE
GAP IS IN TERMS OF SALARY AND SO
THIS IS A RIPPLE EFFECT ON AND
CERTAINLY TRYING TO APPROACH IT
WITH A DIFFERENT LENS IS VERY
DIFFICULT BUT IT REALLY IS BASED
ON THAT SAME PRINCIPLE THAT IT
IS ILLEGAL. TO PAY WOMEN PEOPLE
OF COLOR. A DIFFERENT AMOUNT
BASED ON RACE AND GENDER AND
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE STILL DESPITE WHATEVER IN
PERFECT BILL IS IN FRONT OF YOU.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY ABOUT TRYING TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE GET TO THE CORE
PROBLEM THAT IN THIS STATE IN
THIS COUNTRY THERE ARE STILL
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
ARE BEING PAID. LESSER BECAUSE
OF THEIR RACE AND GENDER AND
DATA. HISTORICAL DATA SHOWING.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO FIND OF
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE TO FALL FOR
THAT SO I VERY MUCH RESPECT
YOUR- OPINIONS AND YOUR COMMENTS. TO SEE NO ONE ELSE WISHING TO
BE RECOGNIZED- YOU CAN YOU KNOW
JUST OF. I'M GONNA COME BACK TO
CLOSE- THE CENTER BUT- YOU KNOW
AGAIN JUST JUST FOR THE RECORD I
KNOW YOU'VE KNOWLEDGE AT- BUT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF DID-
OFFERED ATTEMPT TO OFFER-
AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL AND- IN
AGAIN THAT'S WHY- YOU. CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW THERE'S AN ARGUMENT
THAT YOU GET TIMED OUT AT SOME
POINT WE'VE BEEN MOVING PRETTY
QUICKLY THROUGH. THROUGH
COMMITTEES AND GETTING THE
BILL'S HEARD- BUT- THAT SAID-
AGAIN IT'S APPRECIATED TO HEAR
THAT- AS YOU GO FORWARD AND
SENATOR BECAUSE DRAWS- AND- IN
OTHER SELF- I. HAVE SPOKEN TO-
VERY VERY IMPORTANT YOU KNOW.
THIS COMMITTEE STUFF IS
CERTAINLY ALWAYS A RESOURCE BUT
THE CONTINUE AS YOU SAID-
WORKING WITH THOSE COMMITTEE
SELF AS OPPOSED TO JUST USING IT
AS A VEHICLE FOR DISCUSSION AND-
AGAIN YOU SAID THAT I AM JUST.
TO INSPECT LISTENING HERE IN A
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT- BUT BUT
THAT'S THE BASIS- YOU KNOW FOR
THE SPORT OF THINK THAT YOU WILL
GET TO GET IT OUT TODAY- YOU MAY
CLOSE IN AND ADDRESS ANYTHING
ELSE THAT YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS
THERE I'M GONNA LEAVE MY FINAL
THOSE LAST COMMENTS AS MY
CLOSING SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU-
CONSULTANTS- WE HAVE CENTER
DRAWS OR ON THE RECORD WITH THE
MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI COURTESY I- CHAU
VOGUE FOR TROUBLED NO WRESTLE.
THE REST SO I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN. THAT HAS. THREE ONE WITH
ONE NOT TWENTY OKAY SO THREE
ONE- WITH WITH ONE ABSTAINING
ESSENTIALLY SO- THE BILL'S OUT-
THAT BRINGS US TO. TWO BILLS SET
TO BILLS AND I'M HOPING TO.
RESENT IF ALLOWED IN I'M GOING
TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO. OUR
VICE CHAIR. AT THIS TIME.
SURE. ONE OKAY TWENTY SIX OF THE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- WELCOME
SENATOR CORTESE ARE YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DURING COLLEAGUES ON THE. IT IS
STILL MORNING SOMEHOW IT SEEMS
LIKE MID AFTERNOON ALREADY- SO
GOOD MORNING AND- OFFICIALLY I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX SPONSORED BY THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA IN MANY OTHERS SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WILL EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO KELSEY WAS
RETIREMENT PROGRAM THROUGH
EMPLOYERS WITH AT LEAST ONE
EMPLOYEE INSURING INSURING THAT
NEARLY EVERY WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AS ACCESS TO A
WORKPLACE RETIREMENT SAVINGS
PROGRAM THE KELSEY RICH
RETIREMENT SAVINGS PROGRAM WAS
CREATED. BY SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR ASCENDER DELEON
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH ESTABLISHED
A MANDATE FOR CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS TO PARTICIPATE CAL
SAVERS THAT THEY HAVE AT LEAST
FIVE EMPLOYEES THEY DO NOT
SPONSOR A RETIREMENT PLAN KELSEY
WAS IS AN AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT I
ALREADY AVAILABLE TO EMPLOYEES
IRA I SHOULD SAY WITH NO
EMPLOYER OR FUTURE LIABILITY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW ONLY
EMPLOYERS WITH FIVE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES AS THEY JUST SAID- ARE
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
KELSEY WAS PROGRAM THIS RESULTS
IN THE PROGRAM BE UNAVAILABLE TO
THREE QUARTERS OF A MILLION
CALIFORNIA WORKERS REPRESENTING
ROUGHLY 10% OF THE UNCUT VERSION
SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WILL CLOSE
THAT GAP BY ALLOWING EVEN THE
SMALLEST EMPLOYERS FULL ACCESS
TO THE PROGRAM. EXPANDING-
ELIGIBILITY WELL ALSO REDUCE CA
. FOR EMPLOYER SINCE TEN OF
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYERS HAVE AN
AVERAGE AND ABOVE AVERAGE
EMPLOYEE COUNT SUPPORT YOU WITH
A BOMB BLEW THE CURRENT FIVE
EMPLOYEE THRESHOLD FROM YEAR TO
YEAR. THIS RESULTS IN EMPLOYERS
HAVING TO ADJUST CERTAIN MISTER
PRACTICES ACCORDING TO THEIR
CURRENT SIZE IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH THE MANDATE- WE WANT TO
CORRECT THAT. FAILURE TO
PROPERLY COMPLY WITH THE MANDATE
YEARLY COULD RESULT IN PENALTIES
OR OTHER ISSUES FOR EMPLOYERS.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WOULD
CLARIFY AND SIMPLIFY COMPLIANCE
FOR ALL EMPLOYEES. BUT WITH US
TODAY'S CASEY O'CONNOR
REPRESENTED FROM THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OWN A
RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTERS ON THE
COMMITTEE I AM CASEY O'CONNOR'S
OF LET'S SAY DIRECTOR FOR
TREASURE FIONA MASHI IS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS AND HER. PROXY
AS THE CHAIR OF THE CALIBER OF
THE CALCIUM RICH RETIREMENT
BOARD I WANT TO THANK YOUR
CORTESE FOR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AS ONE OF THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICERS OF THE
STATE OUR OFFICE IS DEDICATED TO
HELPING ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ACHIEVE FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
ENSURING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO THRIVE.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE CAL SAVERS
BOARD THE TREASURE IS COMMITTED
TO THE BOARD'S MISSION TO ENSURE
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE A PATHWAY
TO SAVE FINANCIAL SECURITY IN
RETIREMENT FOR THEIR FUTURE.
PRIVATE RETIREMENT PLANS ARE
IMPORTANT BUT COST COMPLEXITY
AND LIABILITY ARE OFTEN CITED AS
THE TOP REASON EMPLOYERS DO NOT
SPONSOR RETIREMENT PLANS. HEALTH
SAVERS PROVIDES EMPLOYERS A NO
FEE SIMPLE WAY TO HELP THEIR
EMPLOYEES SAVE FOR RETIREMENT.
AS A SENATOR NOTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE SAW A LOT OF
BUSINESSES FLUCTUATE IN SIZE
THEREFORE MAKING IT DIFFICULT
FOR OUR SMALLEST BUSINESSES WHO
FELL BELOW FIVE EMPLOYEES TO
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
STILL IN COMPLIANCE ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR CAL SAVERS. WE'VE ALSO HAD
TO DENY REQUESTS FROM OUR
SMALLEST BUSINESSES WHO TRIED TO
JOIN CAL SAVERS MERELY BECAUSE
IN THE STATUTE IT SAYS FOR FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR MORE WE WANT TO
MAKE IT UNDER EASY TO UNDERSTAND
AND MORE EQUITABLE FOR ALSO THE
SIMPLE BILL IS SHE- TO INCLUDE.
ELIGIBLE TO EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE
Y. OR MORE EMPLOYEE. EXCLUDING
SOLE PROPRIETORS AND I THINK
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IS JUST A SIMPLE CLEAN UP TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THIS BILL DOES
WHAT IT'S INTENDED TO DO AND
OFFER THE SAVINGS PROGRAM TO
ALL. AND AS A CENTER NOTED- CAL
SAVERS IN ROMAN ON IT IS
AUTOMATIC- BUT THESE ACCOUNTS
ARE PORTABLE MEANING THAT SAVERS
CAN KEEP THEM IF THEY MOVE FROM
JOB TO JOB. AND INVESTMENTS ARE
EASY AND IS OPT OUT FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES SO WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND IF
ANYONE DOES HAVE QUESTIONS. HE
SELASKY IS HERE WHO'S OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIBERS.
THANK YOU. BECAUSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH M. MINUTE CONNOR- AND
YOU'RE OUR ONLY LEAD WITNESSES
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
C. NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST ARE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU TO BEGIN A PART OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT WILL START
WITH NINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MUCH CIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
SPOKE. AND NEXT TWELVE LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR CULTURE IS NOT SAYS PARTY
HAVING A COLLECTION FROM ALL
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. WE
HAVE YOUR MIND ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO OUT OF ALL
WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
THIS IS HEIDI PICKMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY OR CAMEO
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
ONE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LUCY SALCEDO CARTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NON. PORT FFT ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING DISTINGUISHED CHAIR
BY KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS LAURIE
CAMERON ON BEHALF OF NAPO
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF F. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS THERE'S A
LOT OF THE RUBALCABA ARESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO AND I AM AN AARP
MEMBER AND VOLUNTEER AND- THAT
THREE POINT THREE MILLION A. A.
R. P. MEMBERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH A R. P. STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
HAVE LINE ONE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES IS THERE A VISION
BEGAN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE
HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS THE
MEDIAN ON MY TEAM WITH THE
LEADER OF THE LAST WEEK THE
KNOWN AS THE NATIONAL COUNCIL.
FOLLOWING STRONG SUPPORT FOR AT
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS LINE IS OPEN. I AM. SIXTY SIX. WE'LL GO WITH NINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS HELLO LEVINE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE MICRO ENTERPRISE
COLLABORATIVE WORK AND ONE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED BY THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
CREATE. AND SO I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THAT DEL. TIELINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAKOBAN AND
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I DON'T FEEL
LIKE REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AFFECT BUILDING
COALITION ON IN SUPPORT OF AT
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT OUR MODERATOR I'M HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FROM ANY OPPOSITION. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION ON
RECORD SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SEEING NONE THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY TO
THE TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX WE WILL BEGIN. TRAIN
OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND I HAVE NO WINNING CAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MATTER MADAM
MODERATOR AND WE WANT TO THANK
ALL OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL
NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I DO. SECRETARY ST-
I'M A BIG. BELIEVER IN THIS
EFFORT I THINK THE DESTRUCTION
OF THE OF THE CAL SAVERS PROGRAM
IS ONE OF THE- BIGGEST MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE'VE DONE IS A
LEGISLATURE IN MANY YEARS AS IT
RELATES TO WORKING PEOPLE AND
THEIR- THERE FEEL VERY BASIC
RIGHT TO ENJOY SOUND RETIREMENT.
AB TWO GLAD DID SUPPORT THE BILL
GLAD TO MOVE THE PROTOTYPE A
GUIDE RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS IS FROM
FOUR THANK YOU. WWE A CO AUTHOR.
OKAY OKAY WE SORRY THE I THINK
WHAT IT CAN PREVENT CLOSE NOBODY
NUMBER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE
THE MOTION BY. NEWMAN INTERNALLY
AND YOU KNOW ASK FOR. ROLE OKAY
MY- THE MOST IS DUE POWER BUT
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CORTESE ALL
RIGHT I A CHOI BOGUE. NOW DORADO
. I WHERE ALL RIGHT I NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT I IT IS FOR EYES TWO ONE
NOW. THAT'S IT YES OKAY. SO NOW
WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL CENTER
COURTESY. SB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU OF YOU
MAY PERCEIVE THANK YOU MISTER.
SURE AND IN MEMBERS SOME PROUD
TO PRESENT SB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
IT'S A BILL THAT WILL PROMOTE
EMPLOYEE WELLNESS AND SAFETY IN
HIGH STRESS INDUSTRIES BY
DEVELOPING A REPLICABLE MODEL OF
WORKER WELLNESS CENTERS THAT CAN
BE APPLIED STATEWIDE AS YOU MAY
RECALL MEMBER ON MAY TWENTY
SIXTH OF LAST YEAR BT EMPLOYEE
ENTERED. THE GUADALUPE YARD IN
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA IN MY
DISTRICT AND BEGAN THE SHOOTING
RAMPAGE THAT KILLED NINE OF HIS
COWORKERS AT THE FACILITY BEFORE
TAKING HIS OWN LIFE THIS WAS THE
DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING IN THE
HISTORY OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. THE TREASURY SENT
SHOCKWAVES THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY AMONG THE
WORKERS THE NEW THE VICTIMS IN
WORK IN THAT COMPLEX. I WORK
WITH B. TWO UNISA MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION WITH THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO RESPOND TO
THE NEEDS OF THE WORKERS BY
STANDING UP RESILIENCY AND
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER. THE
CENTER HAS PROVIDED CRITICAL
BEHAVIOR HALL SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES DEALING
WITH THE GRIEF OF THE MAY TWENTY
SIX SHOOTING. AS A PART OF THE
STATE BUDGET LAST YEAR WE
APPROPRIATED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUNDS THE FUNDS
SUPPORT PROVIDED BY TE CENTER
TO WORKERS UNFORTUNATELY THE
TRAGIC SHOOTING AT BTA IS NOT
ENTIRELY UNCOMMON IN THESE
EFFORTS THUS FAR ARE NOT YET
COMPLETE. HE MAY TWENTY SIX
SHOOTING WAS THIRD WORKPLACE
SHOOTING IN UNDER TWO MONTHS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ACCORDING TO
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY THERE
BEEN THIRTY SEVEN MASS WORKPLACE
SHOOTINGS IN THE LAST THIRTEEN
YEARS AND FIVE OF THOSE THIRT
SEVEN OCCURRED IN SPRING LAST
YEAR. EXPERTS SAY THAN
INDIVIDUALS THAT COMMIT THESE
ACTS ARE LIKELY TO BE RACK
REACTING. TO STRESS IN THE
WORKPLACE WORK HOME. THIS RISE A
WORK FILE. SHOWS THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT FOR WORKERS
TO ENSURE THE TRAGIC EVENTS LIKE
THE B. T. SHOOTING HAPLESS
FREQUENTLY. SB TWELVE NINETY
FOUR CHEESES SCHOOL. BY DRAWING
FROM THE BEST PRACTICES AND
LESSONS LEARNED IT VTA. IN
APPOINTED TO A MODEL THAT CAN BE
REPLICATED STATEWIDE IN THE
FUTURE. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL S.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
CALL COOPERATE WITH BTA. IN
OTHER HEALTH AGENCIES TO PREPARE
A REPORT. WITH THE EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES USED TO BE TO INCREASE
STATEWIDE MODEL THAT CAN BE
APPLIED TO HIGH STRESS
INDUSTRIES ACROSS THE STATE. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE SO THAT WE CAN TAKE THE
FIRST STEP. TOWARDS STOPPING
THIS PATTERN OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE WE'VE SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE NATION.
RIGHT HERE WITH US TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I HAVE FROM A GOOD
FRIEND. IN A SURVIVOR OF THAT
SHOOTING JOHN COURTNEY PRESIDENT
OF AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
LOCAL TWO SIXTY FIVE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MISTER COURTNEY.
THANK YOU DATE. YOUR DADDY WHEN
YOU BEGAN TO SPEAK I GOT VERY
MUCH SO I APOLOGIZE I THINK YOU
CAN HEAR IT IN MY VOICE. THIS A
MOMENT. MY NAME IS JOHN
PRESIDENT AND AGE AND WOULD NOW
THREE UNION LOCAL TWO SIXTY FIVE
IN SAN JOSE. EVERYTHING TRANSIT
WORKERS WITH GTA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. I
TESTIFIED TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY FOR
ALMOST A YEAR AGO ON MAY TWENTY
SIX I WOKE UP WENT TO WORK ANY
OTHER MORNING OF MY- THIS
REPLACE WE WERE MEETING IN A
SMALL ROOM ABOUT TWELVE BY
TWELVE WHEN ONE OF THE WORKERS
PULLED OUT A GUN AND BEGAN
SHOOTING I SCREAMED AT THE
KILLERS STOP SHOOTING INSTEAD HE
POINTED THE GUN AT ME TOLD ME HE
WAS GOING TO SHOOT ME AND RIGHT
BEFORE MY EYES. KILLED SIX
PEOPLE EXPLAINS THIS. IT'S BOTH
. HUMAN BEINGS UNCLES
GRANDFATHERS FATHERS- I BEGAN
YELLING ACTIVE SHOOTER TO MAKE
SURE HAT OTHERS WHO WERE NEARBY
WOULD NOT BE KILLED THE KILLER
WENT ON TO THE NEXT BUILDING
MURDERED THREE MORE WORKERS THAT
PTA FINALLY KILLING HIMSELF.
UNTIL THAT DAY I DIDN'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF HAVING
RESOURCES INTO THIS SUCH AS THE
RESOURCES THE BILL WILL PROVIDE.
HELPING OKAY WITH MENTAL HEALTH
FROM PTSD ANXIETY DEPRESSION I
MEAN TO BE HONEST GOD KNOWS WHAT
ELSE THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF
YOU ALL. SB ONE TWENTY NINE
PROVIDED RESOURCES FOR ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY TO HELP US.
AFFECTED BY THE TRAGEDY AS WE GO
FORWARD THE BEST WE CAN WITH OUR
LIVES ONE OF THE RESOURCES WE
NOW HAVE UP AND RUNNING IT
WORKER WELLNESS CENTER WE CALL
THE FIVE TWENTY SIX RESILIENCY
CENTER. THE FIVE TWENTY SIX
CENTER IS A REAL BEACON OF HOPE
FOR ALL OF OUR WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY HERE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. BEFORE THE TWENTY SIX
OBVIOUSLY HAD NO MAY PLAYBOOK IN
PLACE. THOUSAND DOLLARS GOOD
DEAL WITH MANY HEALTH ISSUES.
OUT FACE. IN ENDICOTT AND WE ARE
NOW IN THE SPOTLIGHT BECAUSE OF
OUR EVENT. I BELIEVE IN MY HEART
. SB NINETY FOUR IF IT HAD BEEN
IN PLACE PRIOR TO THE MASS
SHOOTING THAT I WITNESSED.
ANNELIES WOULD STILL BE INTACT
PEOPLE WHICH TO LIVE TODAY AND
WE WOULD HAVE NOT HAD TO HAVE
HAD DISCUSSION. THE DAY. I TRULY
BELIEVE AND SUPPORT SB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT
WILL LITERALLY SAVE A LOT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MISTER COURTNEY. THANK YOU
AND- VERY SORRY FOR WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH NOT ONLY YOURSELF
BUT YOUR MEMBERS AND ALL THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE- SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION. ARM. YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO
SAY WHAT YOU JUST SHARED WITH US
IS EXTREMELY POWERFUL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE KNOW
HOW SUPPORTIVE YOU ARE WONDERING
TODAY ARE. AND THAT'S- ALL THE
THANKS. WE HAVE. MADE ME HAVE
WELL CAN I SAY THANK YOU- WE
HAVE ANY MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. YOU'RE IN THE ROOM
PLEASE COME FORWARD. YES MA'AM
I'M SURE MEMBERSHIP AND GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF TH CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE BOARD OF THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT TRANSIT
UNION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL IN OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AT PTA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE- LIKE TO SPEAK.
YOU'RE IN THE ROOM SEE NON
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE ANY ON THE
- TELECONFERENCE. THANK YOU IN
ORDER TO SPEAK FOR IN FAVOR OF
F. P. TWELVE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. AND WE'LL START WITH LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
YOU I'M SURE MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPLORE. WE HAVE
LINE ONE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH DEROGATIS AGAIN-
TEMP CISCO BILLINGTREE
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWENTY TWO SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT SENATE BILL-
FOR- THE TRAGEDY THAT HE HEARD
IN THE PAST. I THINK IT WAS A
TRAGEDY- THE PERSON THAT SPOKE.
FOUR SIX THREE- NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE- SOMETHING OF
THAT MAGNITUDE- AND- YES I DO
SUPPORT- THANK YOU ALL FEEL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING IN NEXT WE HAVE LIFE
ONE EIGHTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING PAUL WOODS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S VISORS ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN HERE. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WE DON'T HAVE A LEAD. WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SEEN NON MODERATOR COULD WE MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE-
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE NINETY
FOUR. IN OPPOSITION THE CLUB
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I
HAVE NO I THINK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR NO
FUTURE THERE ONCE WITH THE BILL.
LET YOUR AYE I JUST WANT TO
SALUTE MR QUARTEY FOR HIS HIS
COURAGE IN COMING. AS A WIN IS
TODAY THE CAT THERE IS
IMPRESSIVE THAT'S HARD TO DO- I
COMMEND YOU I'M NOT SURE I COULD
DO IT FOR. SIMILAR TO ANYTHING.
OKAY THE- YOU'VE LEFT US- UNABLE
TO SAY ANYTHING MORE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WILSHIRE- IT'S
OBVIOUSLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FOLLOW-
JOHN COURTNEY'S TESTIMONY- WITH
ANYTHING ADDITIVE BUT- BUT I
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND HIM IN IT.
GIVEN THAT- A CENTER WHERE NAY
PRETTY CLEAR OR FAMILIAR WITH-
ALL THIS DON'T THE SOUTH BAY-
I'VE WORKED PARTICULARLY CLOSE
WITH WITH MR COURTNEY I WAS
TEXTING HIM FROM THE SENATE
FLOOR- THE MORNING OF- THE
MORNING OF THE SHOOTING
UNFORTUNATELY- HE DROPPED HIS
HIS PHONE A TO KEEP MOVING IT TO
KEEP WARNING PEOPLE- WHAT I WANT
TO SAY IS. IN TERMS OF HIS
COURAGE WHICH YOU JUST HEARD IN
SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE OR THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT IMAGINE DOING
THAT IT PTA MEETINGS IMAGINE
DOING THAT AT RALLIES THE
MEASURE SHOWING UP. RALLIED THE
TROOPS COMFORTING- THE PEOPLE
THAT. ARE YOUR COWORKERS THAT
YOU REPRESENT IN- INFORMAL UNIT
CAPACITY- LABOR CAPACITY- IN IN
IN TALKING TO US EVEN PREPARING
FOR TESTIMONY LIKE THIS- JUST
ONE CITY JOHN WE CONTINUE TO IT
TO BE. AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT YOU-
IN ANY OF YOUR NEEDS IF YOU'RE
STILL ON THE LINE OF LISTENING-
WE HEALTH WELLNESS CENTRES NOW
UNDER MIDDLE SCHOOLS. YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL INVESTING IN WELLNESS
CENTERS- ON THE EDUCATION FRONT
VERY AGGRESSIVELY WHAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE YET IS- SET UP THE
TEMPLATE FOR YOU KNOW INVESTING
IN THOSE SAME KIND OF- REFERRAL
WELLNESS CENTERS- EVEN IF EVEN
IN PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYMENT
CENTERS THAT ARE HIGH STRESS.
LIKE TRANSIT OPERATIONS SO-
THAT'S WERE BARKING ON HERE IN.
IT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU SAN-
WILL MOVE ON NOW WE HAVE A- THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. I'M SORRY. OKAY WE ARE.
MY OLDER BROTHER I THOUGHT YOU
HAD DONE. OKAY GREAT THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED- CONSULTANT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY ALL RIGHT FOR TO SEE I
OWE TO A VOGUE THE RUSSELL HI.
THE REST OF AYE LAYERED HI THERE
I NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN AYE.
HAS FOR WE CAN PUT ON CALL UNCLE
OKAY. THANKS YES. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO FOR PRESIDING- IN
THE- WE HAVE SOME. BILLS TO TAKE
UP FOR A ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND I THINK WE NEED TO
DO THAT AT THIS TIME I DON'T
KNOW CENTER DRAWS- IS IN ROUTE
BACK RBC AS WE STATED EARLIER
PEOPLE WERE INCLUDING MYSELF FOR
ARE EXPECTED TO BE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES AT OUR MEETING
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND I ONLY SAY
THAT FOR PUBLIC DISSEMINATION IN
CASE PEOPLE ARE WONDERING. WHY
PEOPLE ARE COMING OR GOING OR
TEMPORARILY ABSENT BUT- HAVING
NO INDICATION FROM HER THAT
SHE'S GOING TO BE BACK WHICH
ABOVE. THE RESIDUE I'M SORRY WHO
TROUBLED- IS SHE ON HER WAY
BACK. OKAY SO WE WILL. FOR ME WE
CAN START TAKING THE ONES THAT
IN THE IN THE COME BACK AROUND
IN INCOME THROUGH THE ROLE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT OKAY- TO CONSULT
WITH SERVICE WHEN PROCEED ALONG
THOSE LINES. THAT'S CORRECT YEP
THAT'S CORRECT IF YOU VOTED TO-
IT WOULD LOOK NICE AND. GROUP.
THANK YOU. WE NEED TO DO PARMI.
LET HIM KNOW A DRAWS SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND START
ON THE- ON THE- YEAH W. IF YOU
LET HIM KNOW WITH THERE'S
INITIALLY COMING BACK THERE MAY
BE A MOTION TO VOTE ON. OKAY WE
CAN PROCEED WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US NOW. OKAY SO ITEM
TWO S. B. ELEVEN SIXTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN I. REBEKAH CALL. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I. I SB FORTINO
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS NEWMAN. THE
NEW MANATT BOATING. THE BILL
HAS- THREE KNOWS AND ONE NOT
VOTING AND WHEN I CENTER- SO-
THAT VOTE- THAT BILL FEELS.
THANK YOU. S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS NEWMAN. NEWMAN
NOT VOTING. THE BILL HAS THREE
ICE ONE KNOW WHEN UPLOADING
THREE GUYS ONE NO ONE NOT VOTING
THAT THERE WAS A.
WE WILL- IT IS ESSENTIALLY WERE
WERE RECESSED FOR WHAT WE HOPE
IS JUST A COUPLE OF MINUTES-
WE'RE EXPECTING SENATOR- CHOATE
BOGUE BACK HERE BY SURELY
COMMITTEE- WE CAN RESUME TAKING
UP- VOTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- AS
WELL AS POTENTIALLY- ANOTHER
MOTION. THANK YOU. WILL.
WE ARE RECONVENING THE- LABOUR
COMMITTEE. AHMED I'M CONSULTED
WOULD YOU MIND I LIVED IN THE
CALLS. SURE FILE ITEM TWO S. B.
ELEVEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS I
CHORE BUG. NOT VOTING. THAT BILL
. IS FOR EYES ZERO HE SAID. THE
BILL IS OUT. WITH THE FINAL OUR
NEXT. S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS BUT
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS A SHOW ABOUT.
ME ONE SECOND NO PROBLEM THAT
WOULD BE PORTANTINO'S BELL FILE
ITEM THREE.
I SUPPORT I CHOI BOGUE I. FILE
ITEM FOR S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
BUT FIRST AMEND AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
A CHAU A BUG. NOT VOTING. THE
BILL HAS FOUR EYES ZERO. AND I
THINK. FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
A CHOI BOGUE HI I. THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE ZERO FIVE NOTHING.
WE'LL BE TAKING A SMALL RECESS
UNTIL ARCHER GETS BACK THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE ARE A. YOU'RE GOING
TO. GO BACK TO SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY WHICH WAS PRESENTED
EARLIER BY SENATOR DOLLY BUT
WITHOUT DISPOSITION- IN LESS
GIVE- WE WERE ABLE TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION AT THIS TIME LET ME
JUST PUT IT OUT THAT WAY. M.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE A
MISTER CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO- FOR
ONLY MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE AYE
SENATOR DOLLY SPELL FOURTEEN
TWENTY. OKAY SO THERE IS A
MOTION TO MOVE SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SINCE ALMOST CALL ROLE
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. COURTESY NO
COURTESY NOW A CHOI BOGUE I THE
TROUBLE I THE RUSSELL. LAYARD
NEWMAN. NEWMAN NOW. THAT HAS WHO
KNOWS ONE NINE AND TWO AND A
HALF. GET TO KNOWS ONE I IN. THE
END TO NOT VOTING FOR THOSE AT
UP TO FIVE OKAY TWO TWO KNOWS
ONE I TO NOT VOTING- SO THE BILL
FAILS HERE NOT LET THE RECORD
SHOW THAT RECONSIDERATION WAS
REQUESTED- AND GRANTED WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU. I BELIEVE
THAT CONCLUDES ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY. IN I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE MOST PARTICULARLY-
COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EXCELLENT JOB AGAIN AND NOT
JUST TODAY BUT GETTING THIS-
READY- TODAY WORKING WITH SO
MANY AUTHORS TO GIVE BILLS- HE
AND HIM BETTER. IN A BETTER
PLACE TO MOVE ALONG WHICH WE
HEARD IN IN MUCH OF THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND IN MUCH OF
THE COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED- AND I THINK. NO
HELP TO STEP OF A MORE EFFICIENT
MEETING TODAY SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY IN MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE BEEN
MONITORING THE MEETING- WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WE WILL NOW
ADJOURN INTO OR NOT OUR NEXT
REGULARLY SCHEDULED MEETING
WHENEVER THAT MAY BE.